Do you feel ready?
You believe in God?
I believe in God with often they don't
really know.
I mean like we are supported by
invisible forces.
That kind.
I love that video about your,
uh,
your grandfather.
You obviously love him.
He said maybe.
What is he still the most important male
figure in your life?
Yeah.
He's probably the only important male
figure of my life,
which is a strong statement to make,
but that's about right.
Do you have a good female figures in
your life?
Women.
I try.
I try to be that um,
you know,
I come from a very sort of broken crazy
family.
Okay.
I heard that sort of known of your
uncles had been incarcerated.
So you come from a family where the
crime is part of the story.
Yeah.
I mean they're not nine of them,
but five of the nine of them all spend
some time in prison and that sort of
trickled down and I have cousins that
have spent time in prison and it was
just a part of my story growing up and
it wasn't particularly unique.
It's so it's a weird thing to say,
but in the retrospect like that seems
normal to me,
like we're going to go see your uncle in
prison.
Okay,
sure.
That's what you do normal for a lot of
people.
It's not extraordinary.
Yeah.
Which really lets you know that you can
create different simulations and
different pockets of society and until
you travel outside of it to have a
different experience.
You think it's just the norm.
When did that happen for you?
When did your life transition from?
What was your early determining context
to what was the thing that should change
first few candies?
Well,
I think I was always sort of an alien
child.
Like my mother says all the time when I
was a kid,
they were just weirded out by me.
Like I never cried.
They always thought I could like
understand them as a baby in the crib,
which is really bizarre.
But the earliest thing that I remember
was the first play date,
which was in kindergarten class.
I was five years old and there was a
girl named Lindsey to.
She was this blonde girl with blue eyes
and we became fast friends.
I don't,
I don't think we had reading class
together and her mother invited me over
for a play date and I went to her house
and I was just shocked that people lived
in the way that she lived.
She lived in the suburbs.
She had a massive house.
She had this Victorian concept room.
She had a nanny,
she had a playroom and I was.
I just remember being shocked that this
was even a part of life because prior to
obviously I existed within the realm of
my family.
I lived in a really small apartment.
Me and my two sisters shared a room in a
low income housing a building and it
just blew my mind.
So I think when I was a really small kid
I was already considering like,
how is this asking the question at least
which is important in order to get the
answer.
How could people be living such
different lives and you either take two
approaches to it.
You either say,
I hate rich people because they live
that way,
or I want to become a rich person and
learn how to live that way.
I think I've always been curious about
success and wanted to learn how to be
successful myself,
so my path was somewhat natural in that
regard.
I never,
I never hated rich people.
It's a very weird thing to me that
people demonize the rich.
No,
I think he hates a terrible emotion
because it,
it,
it's,
you harvest it internally,
so if you hate someone you hate that
they're okay.
They don't,
they don't feel that.
So you always been an aspirational even
when you were a child.
If it sounds to me from what little
you've told me already that you sounds
like you had an unusual emotional state,
that you were sort of quite an
independent person.
Yes.
And that you're.
I mean,
even watching you,
I've watched quite a lot of your videos
and the interviews.
You're very powerful person.
You've got driven on you.
You've got a strong presence.
Yeah,
and I've always had that,
like my teachers hated me growing up
because I was just extremely assertive.
I think think about the functional
educated.
That's a very good question.
I think I like to say that I was self
educated because you don't learn
anything in school.
You learn propaganda,
you learn how to function in society and
the way that the government and society
wants you to function.
Um,
so I like to think that because I always
had to earn my way through life.
My parents couldn't afford to put me
through school.
My parents started paying for anything
for me.
Um,
when I turned 14 years old I was kicked
out of my house and I was living with a
boyfriend for six months.
I was one of those kids,
you know,
um,
and so I,
I sort of was self taught and I was
constantly pushing back against
arbitrary authority.
Arbitrary Authority mean that because
I'm the teacher and I say,
go left,
go left.
Well,
no,
tell me why I should go left.
I need to like to be a little bit,
a little bit of reasoning behind this.
Um,
I was always a critical thinker my
entire life,
um,
and that sort of,
I,
but I didn't go to,
I went to university for a couple of
years and then dropped out.
So I think I'm so smart because I didn't
go to university and do that thing where
you said that your auto didact self
educated person,
what was your reading?
Oh,
okay.
So I,
when I was a small kid,
I loved books.
I would get totally lost in novels and
it was a lot of fiction novels that I
grew up on.
I was reading books,
very bizarre.
I mean to be like a five year old
reading,
uh,
an eight year old reading Nora Roberts
and like Dean Koontz and I just,
I love to get wrapped up in fiction
novels.
Uh,
so that helped obviously in terms of
just my vocabulary and ability to
communicate.
I was always reading.
I was a big reader or total dweeb.
I'm at home.
I was cool in school,
but it was a total dweeb at home.
Uh,
and I remember racing even when I was in
fifth grade to read the Harry Potter
books,
like one of those people that was in
line waiting for them.
She's a disaster now,
by the way,
but issue,
I mean her books are very good.
I'm a politically,
she a total disaster.
She should stick to fiction because she
doesn't understand reality.
She doesn't,
she really does.
And I'm sorry.
She's wonderful worlds she created
though.
People just get lost inside of,
um,
but yeah,
I didn't start reading political chat
and you're fine.
Get,
get comfortable.
We're going to be in here for,
you know,
comfortable.
They're not leaving until we agree on
absolutely everything.
I have you in a mega hats.
I'm wearing it already,
but just very nice.
Nice.
So yeah,
I dunno,
I didn't start reading I guess non
fiction until I got interested in
nonfiction and politics and things of
that nature.
And then I started reading Milton
Friedman and Dr Thomas Soul.
Ooh.
I haven't understood it.
Any of these references,
like even those fictional ones was
reading when you're a kid.
Now,
will these Milton,
these modern wars,
the recent ones,
you know,
Milton Friedman,
the economists and Dr Thomas Soul is
also an economist.
Um,
and,
but he,
he's a,
he's a black economist,
which was the most important reading
that I could've done because he just
completely makes you understand that
people are using and manipulating you,
uh,
because of the color of your skin.
And he just uses fact based logic and
reasons and world history.
And we'll bring you backward and forward
and show you a basic theses like,
um,
they make you think that because you're
a minority,
that means that you're behind.
And that's the history of the world.
Tells us that's not true,
you know,
and the Ottoman Empire,
uh,
the Greeks owned the bank,
so it was a Turkish empire,
the Greek zone,
the banks.
And we're doing the best in that
economy.
So he just goes through,
um,
world history and just shows you pretty
much all of the fallacies and all of the
emotional arguments that are made and
basically tells you if you want to get
ahead in life and start from nothing,
you have to abandon these arguments is
emotional arguments and understand the
facts and how it is that you can start
behind and get ahead.
And that's what I chose to do.
Do you think there were certain
philosophical ideas that may have a
truth to them when practiced on the
level of the individual,
but when translated to a social scale
become more complex and break down a
deal?
Oh sure.
Socialism,
because it's Utopian because it takes it
about individualism and self
[inaudible].
Like what,
what,
what?
When,
I feel kindness is your powerful person.
You're driven,
you've come from nothing and you've
achieved a lot in your life and it feels
to me at least not to suggest this to
you because you've not directly said
this or I'm actually.
I think you maybe have directly say
stuff like,
well,
if I can do this,
you should do it.
Like now.
But that kind of for me is to deny your
unique abilities and your unique
qualities.
Even having drive the willingness
to work hard is in itself an endowment.
It's why don't say you can do what I've
done.
Right?
I don't say that you're going to follow
everything that I've done.
I actually hope that my kids never had
to live through,
you know,
or see the things that I had to see
growing up.
Why would I want that?
I don't think people should.
I mean just,
I don't want my children to,
to go see their uncle's in prison or to
struggle financially and not to be able
to afford to go on a school trip.
I don't think that that's a necessary
thing for you to understand how to
become successful.
Um,
but what I do demand is that people
abandoned a victim mentality,
right?
I think that that is,
has become a cancer in our society to
Mintel.
Give me,
give us some background on it because
some people won't know what you mean.
It's just the oppression.
Olympics,
you know,
everybody wants to say I deserve more
because I'm more oppressed than you.
Oh,
okay,
well you might say,
I might say that I'm more pressed than
you because I'm black and you're white,
so instantly I'm more pressed and I
deserve more than my voice should be
louder.
And then we say,
okay,
well you're a male and I'm a,
I'm a woman,
so instantly I deserve even more because
I'm a woman and you're a male and women
are more oppressed,
which is totally a lie.
Um,
and I should have my voice heard louder
and then you keep going gay,
straight and they've created all of
these little,
these little pockets and you have to
figure out who is the most depressed
person.
I guess it would be a disabled black
female gay person would probably be the
most.
If you want to win the oppression
Olympics,
that's it.
And everyone should fawn over you and
everything you say should count and
should matter.
And it's,
it's absolute crap.
The victim mentality is what's stopping
most people from getting from point a to
point b should be mean.
But if I imagine a guy disabled and if
you are gay,
disable a black female female,
if I imagine that person,
I don't like it and I'm sure there's
even within that category,
I'm sure there's lots of lots of and
lots of variety.
But when I think of the most powerful
people in the world and the people who
have the most influence,
not many of them are gay,
disabled,
black females.
So I felt,
well I'm not a by the way a kind of,
you know,
just so you know,
where we're starting from.
I feel like the difference between MSNBC
and Breitbart and trump and Obama is so
small as to be irrelevant for my
political standpoint.
These are what I would call the system.
Right?
I suppose what I'm trying to illustrate,
candice,
is that it's relative for me.
None of those people are offering the
kind of social change that's required to
create the systems that human beings
deserve.
Now like so what is yours to me is that
you have a tremendous faith in the
ability of the individual to create
their own destiny.
Why wouldn't you?
Because you've lived it,
but do you think that that's applicable
to all individuals?
I think 100 percent if it,
unless there are of course policies in
place that are preventing you from doing
that.
There are not in America at this moment
in time.
So they actually were forming our own
oppression by buying into the idea of
oppression.
Um,
you know,
one of the things that harmed the black
community the most or these last six
years has been the welfare state.
That's what's happening in France right
now.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't.
Giving handouts and creating a giant
government and not creating a,
you know,
incentives for people work,
which is what people want to do.
It's the human spirit that governments
don't seem to understand that policies
that are socialists don't seem to
understand.
They don't account for the human spirit.
We want to be valuable.
We want to create.
Um,
so when you remove all of that,
you end up with people that are
oppressed and with a variety of problems
and you can pick a ton of problems
within the black community that I'm
trying to reverse.
It all starts with abandoning the victim
mentality and the government tells me
that I should feel bad for myself for
being a,
a woman and being black and make me
understand that I'm behind in society.
You know,
those are the racists.
Don't tell me that I need to feel bad
about myself.
I don't feel that way and they sit and
they insist that you do so.
The greatest challenge and and also the
most fun I think that I have on these
college campuses,
is that you want to see if a black
person,
you want to see who the real racists
are.
Tell you.
Tell people that as a black person you
don't see yourself as a victim.
They lose their goddamn minds.
That's why they hate me.
Read the articles about me.
They call me a neo Nazi.
I mean the Guardian,
right?
Neo Nazi,
a supporter of white supremacy because I
believe that I can do whatever I want in
my life because I have confidence.
What does that tell you?
That they're rushing to smear me because
I believe that black people can do it
without government handouts.
It means that they insist that black
people do it with government handouts.
Otherwise they'd say,
all right,
she has a perspective.
I don't make any policies.
I'm not in the government.
I'm not running for office.
Why does it bother them so much?
Right.
Me,
like I feel you,
but what I'm saying,
it's just like,
where is compassion and love in your
philosophy?
Where is the place for that?
Uh,
well,
what do you mean?
If somebody,
compassion to me is not telling people
that they should be coddled because of
the color of their skin.
I think that that's,
that's,
I've seen that over and like a button.
This is what will,
let me tell you this.
I've thought like say my background
doesn't sound nearly as challenging as
your call from him prior to celebrity,
which I'm imagining there anything you
want to know about me,
but the prior to that,
like I grew up in an ordinary household,
single parent family.
My mom was sick a lot when I was a kid.
I had have intermittent access with my
bad,
you know,
relatively regular.
But like that,
my parents weren't together and then I
became a crack and heroin addict when I
was sort of in my late teens and I feel
that there are what I want to say,
like I feel that there were social
factors there.
I think if I was from a different
background,
had access to different resources that I
may have received.
Psychological,
spiritual input,
different points now like I'm not
complaining about my life.
I've got money and got good family and
stuff and I'm really,
really happy.
But I think to deny social factors in
the cultivation of the individual really
plays into the hands of the already.
Okay.
Before.
Oh,
but I don't,
I actually don't deny those social
factors.
I tell people at the biggest problem
facing the black community as father
absence.
But that's being incentivized by our
government.
So the blue,
the black single motherhood rate was 23
percent in 19 sixties before welfare
programs were implemented today at 74
percent in the black community.
That's because they literally will give
a black mother more money from the
government if the father doesn't live in
the home.
I'm actually really,
I really believe in a two parent home,
but you can just look at the statistics
to see that children are better off when
they have two parents.
But think about what's perpetuated in
our media.
Think about radicalize feminism.
We can do it without men.
F meant we hate men.
That's why I fight these concepts
because what you're talking about is
true.
That's not what people are talking
about,
the political realm.
They want to get rid of all of that in
favor of more government,
more government,
more government.
It's,
it's become increasingly radicalized and
it's harming the individual and their
chances when you come from a two parent
home versus a single parent.
Uh,
there are,
there are tons of statistics that prove
that what you're saying is right.
But my compassion towards that is when I
go and I combat feminism right when I go
and I were a hymn to shirt to the Brett
Kavanaugh,
um,
hearings and tobacco because I don't
believe in the me too movement,
right?
I think it's been radicalized.
I think that it's,
it's,
it's a harmful feminism.
I don't even like calling it feminism
because it's,
it's just a means for people to secure
power,
um,
and it's cloaked as feminism and that's,
that's how I exercise compassionate
exercise,
compassion.
When I go fight for the first step backs
and I understand that many people that
are in prison are in prison because they
grew up in that environment where they
didn't have any parents raising them.
My mother grew up in group homes,
um,
and didn't graduate high school.
She didn't end up in prison,
but she could have very well could have.
And so will you exercise compassion by
having those conversations?
Those are the conversations that are
being had at the political level or even
remote accessing compassionate.
I think that was exercising analysis,
critical thought and the intellect,
which I would never challenge you on.
Your obviously very adept and very
strong in each of those areas.
Let me,
let's go into different territory for a
moment.
Am I right in thinking that you suffered
from anorexia?
That's correct.
Younger?
Yes.
I suffered from anorexia for about four
years.
Wow.
That's pretty serious.
How's your eating now?
I can't stop eating,
so probably me,
what the next year was like.
Well,
what's interesting is that,
and you're an interesting person to talk
to you about this because there is a
spiritual component of Anorexia when,
when there is,
when,
when you start,
when you starve the body,
the mind.
That's why people do this,
these fastings and many religions,
when you,
when you starve the body,
there's almost a mental clarity that
takes over.
And that's what I think becomes
addicting for most people.
Like for me was never about weight.
And for most people it's not about
weight.
Um,
it's usually,
I mean,
when you learn about in Iraq,
so they tell you that it's usually a
manifestation of people trying to assert
control over their lives.
And that's what it is.
It's the one thing you can control when
you feel like there's chaos is what you
put in your mouth and your body.
Um,
so that was for me,
after going through a unique situation
and feeling that my whole life was out
of control,
I just manifested as an eating disorder.
And I had it for four years on and off.
But like,
you know,
if you saw pictures,
I mean I was like 30 pounds skinnier,
maybe even 40 pounds skinnier than I am
now,
which is insane if you get any help.
No,
I helped myself,
which is crazy.
Right?
But I mean,
what was I going to go,
go,
go talk to.
I'm a smart person.
So I think it's,
it's harder.
And I don't know this I'm saying this as
a thought,
you know,
Jordan peers don't have to tell me if
I'm right or wrong.
He's the one that's got the,
the doctorate for this stuff.
But I think that it's really hard for
people that have a higher Iq to go get
help.
We're not the a one time that I went to
a therapist,
it was with my parents,
my parents side,
they're going to try therapy.
The woman was just,
she was just a total moron.
I mean literally everything that she was
trying to say to me,
my family wasn't helpful and I think
that me feeling like I didn't find
someone that was smart in the chair
probably sort of turned me off.
But if I had sat down with Dr Jordan
Peterson first,
I probably would be like,
yeah,
therapy is great.
Uh,
but no,
I didn't,
I,
I just got better.
The therapy was ineffective because
you've found the therapist
intellectually and analytically inept,
but you can't just breeze into.
I just got better because anorexia that
very,
very serious mental condition and I've
got friends that are suffering with that
and it's like almost I'm a drug addict,
a recovering drug addict.
Like my own experience with addiction
is,
is precisely that.
It's trying to deal with a deficit.
No,
my belief is that it's a spiritual
deficit or lack of connection in a
dissatisfaction with the material world
and inability to allied into systems
that seem erroneous,
duplicitous,
meaningless,
and are powerful.
Need for some values,
some spirit now,
like we're not like,
I feel like perhaps there's a
comparable.
The addiction is underscored by,
I want to say some certain universal's,
whether it's an eating disorder,
sexual obsessions or,
or,
you know,
like obviously drug addiction.
Um,
what I'm curious about is how that would
be resolved,
how that would end with that.
Identify the issue.
And what caused me to illustrator,
I actually realized that I went through
this experience in high school that was
classified as a hate crime.
What was that?
It was a racist lands.
Well,
I don't consider them racist.
I think that that was part of the reason
that I caused an eating disorder,
but they left me racist voicemails and
then it became the sore.
But I don't consider that.
But that is.
Does that make an individual but
individual racist?
That's the question.
Can you do something without having to
carry a label for the rest of your life?
Can you say something off pudding,
which I'm sure you've done many times or
right.
Does that make homophobic,
does that make you a racist,
that make you a sexist?
Can you do an app without having to
carry a label for the rest of your life?
Okay.
So I'm not actually that.
That's my point.
So just for this situation,
there's no forgiveness.
How are we going to them?
That was my problem.
So this,
the.
They did something.
It was remarkably stupid.
We were a nice tool.
They left racist voice.
So they said,
well,
I don't think I can say those words on
here,
but you can name words your way through
it.
Okay,
so like a dirty word,
a feather,
that dirty and word.
We're gonna.
Put a bullet in the back of your head
like Martin Luther King.
Right?
Terrible stuff.
I brought up a lot of African Americans,
but why did they do that?
Right?
Nobody cares about the why.
They just want to rush and call people
racist.
Okay,
I'm still adjusting and here's how I got
through my name's sorter.
So this thing gets happened to,
gets taken out of control.
It gets blown up.
It's on the front page of a newspaper
and suddenly people are discussing you
and I,
I'm a,
I'm in high school.
I'm 17 years old.
It's what people want.
It didn't want that to be,
you know,
my high school story,
especially getting ready to go to
school.
And your personal experience with
reappropriate it and told back to you
that you used as an object in someone
else's narrative.
That's exactly correct.
And,
and then now called the victim.
Terrible racism before you experienced
really bad.
I'm going to challenge you and I'm going
to challenge you on on the list.
I'm going to challenge you on that.
Have happened from there.
I'm going to challenge you on that
already.
So you say that's terrible.
Racism that I experienced.
Okay.
Or,
or a couple of high school kids for.
There were four kids in that car.
One of them I knew,
three had never laid eyes on me and
never even seen me.
The the,
the youngest person in the car was 14.
Are Really gonna label a 14 year old
racist for the rest of their life.
I mean this is insane,
but of course it sells.
Newspapers write this terrible thing
happened in our town and people suddenly
are invested in and moms are suburban
moms or writing letters to the editor
and everyone's like,
you know,
in this because nothing happens and now
they have something that's happened and
the media took what should have been a
teaching moment for children.
Okay.
Why'd they do it?
Well,
maybe they had their first beer.
One guy in the car is upset with me
because I stopped hanging out with him.
Was I got my first boyfriend,
he said we're going to call her and
leave her a voicemail and she's black.
Okay.
You gave a drunk drunk 14 year olds a
phone.
By the way,
there's no emotional connection.
Nobody ever talks about technology and
how easy it is to be mean now.
Right?
You can't do that to my face or they
have called me those things to my face.
No,
of course not.
It's hard to be mean in person,
but leaving a voicemail,
I'll say anything to this cup.
Right?
This is Russell brand.
I'll say anything goes God Damn Cup into
the Russell brand.
Okay.
But this is what I'm saying.
So people don't even consider that.
We were the first generation that had
facebook,
instagram,
and I think,
uh,
it's not pronouncing instagram.
It's a strange website.
Instagram,
instagram,
instagram.
Someone on a penny farthing bicycle
guard passed onto.
Sounds better that way we should be
calling it instagram on the emphasis on
the last syllable of instagram.
I'm coming with you on that journey now.
It seems to me that that was a traumatic
incident and your response to it was nrx
here.
Yeah,
which free to me,
but I think it's admirable that you're
willing to be forgiving of the
perpetrators of that,
you know,
because they,
admittedly we're kids,
but I don't think that,
that there's a few things that I think
and also agree with you
that the media capitalize on certain
types of hysterical and like a short
kind of hysterical attitude because it
sells,
you know,
I don't think there is a genuine.
Oh No,
we're actually really shocked.
At least racism happen.
How can we in the,
I don't mean that the energy that moves
papers around or no,
I would agree with you on that as well.
But uh,
but the fact that your being forgiving
of that incident and willing to let go
of that incident doesn't negate for me
the fact that the particular language
they used may have been socially
resourced.
I just want to ask you about some things
that ever happened to me the other day.
I was like,
uh,
like there's a English black footballer
called Raheem Sterling.
Bloody good football actually soccer
player in your language.
And like,
uh,
someone called him a Eva Manc see unt
black.
See unt,
so like,
uh,
he's pissed off about it.
Raheem Sterling got.
Yeah,
yeah.
That guy.
Yeah.
The guy lost his job,
like uh,
you know,
we can discuss that aspect of it in a
minute.
But like what I was like in Raheem
Sterling,
like instagrammed,
I instagrammed instagram.
Instagram's a post saying like,
here's two stories.
One is about like a black footballer by
and his Mama House once about White
Footballer bind his Mama House and the
one about the white football,
it's like lovely young white football up
by his mom house.
And the one about the black football a
by,
at his momma house is flash little
bastard buys mom house,
right?
It's like I'm Raheem Sterling
Brilliantly like sort of selects these
two stories about the same subject and
notes how one is rendered as a kind of
like negatively and one is rendered
positively.
Stanley says that this is racially
motivated now.
Like I don't think I need beer.
A black person to say yeah.
That for me aligns with the way that the
media functions in perpetuating certain
narratives.
And whilst you say the perpetuation of
the victim narrative is disempowering
African Americans or perhaps even black
people were white,
I'm not fully sure of how,
uh,
the breadth of your philosophy,
I think it is a,
um,
what I want to say,
a myopic to suggest that the powerful
cultural narratives and historic
oppression don't play a part in people's
current economic poverty.
Whilst the way out of that I would
accept except would be into a individual
culpability and individual will.
Not everyone has that.
Everyone has that drive,
that power.
Some people need support now with the
role of the state and the veracity of
the state's intentions are certainly
things I question as well.
Do I think that the Democrat Party or
super kind,
wonderful people?
Well,
we have a look at the last 20 years.
How did that work out?
How was,
how were African Americans treated under
Barack Obama?
Like,
so we've got the evidence that date is
in.
It's neither party worked particularly
well,
but for me to deny that there is an
impact of social,
economic and historic conditions on the
individual experience of paypal.
And that,
that those conditions are not affected
by race for me.
I don't think that's true.
Well,
first off,
I want to go to your two articles
because you use the word myopic.
Okay?
You,
you used a sample sale,
a sample of two articles to come up with
this great conclusion is every single
room,
I understand that as every single
article about a black person buying a
house negative or did you find one that
wasn't going to do a comparison?
Now hold on.
Every single article of a white person
buying a house positive or did you find
article of white person positive and now
you've used as to say at this means that
every single white person and article
articles written about is true or false.
I have a problem with this data set and
this is what we see over and over again.
It's the same thing that they do and
they extract the 16 unarmed black men
that are shot and killed by police
officers every year.
Forget to mention that there's a higher
rate for white people.
You did the exact same thing that I
can't stand.
This was actually,
I found,
I found two articles at universal.
I'm Russell brand calm down because
firstly it was rocking sterling faster.
That counts for times that by a
thousand.
No,
hold on.
What I'm saying is is you get a number
and you can blow him out because he's
probably better with media creates
simulation one side by side and now it's
universal truth here on the Russell
brands.
Listen to me for a second please.
What I'm saying is is that whilst of
course all of us can construct
narratives by selecting information that
supports our idea,
Raheem Sterling didn't do this in a bit
on the Saturday.
Someone screams racial abuse him on the
next day.
He goes,
oh look,
I'm not surprised because you know,
because I experienced a lot of this
treatment at a subtler level in the
white arm.
How did in the press,
this is he's personal experienced that
Ryan is recounting and then we look at
the rest of the information and say,
oh,
what does it seem to be like for young
black men in England is are there any
commonalities economically?
Are there any judicial or criminal
issues where there's a commonality?
It's not just that these narratives
being cherry picked,
there is also the date of receipt on
incarceration of young black men in
America because we are
disproportionately commit crimes in
America.
Are we not supposed to be arrested
because we're all doing the same thing.
They're counted your.
You're extracting that,
but if they do it without saying,
well,
what are the economic conditions in
America,
but now we're missing this.
You're missing this.
I agree that we have been,
that we are.
We are economically depressed as black
Americans.
What I'm talking about,
what we disagree on is the solution.
Okay,
well,
economically depressed because we bought
into the myth that government is going
to fix our problems.
We have disproportionately been voting
for Democrats for the last 60 years.
Okay,
so all of our problems are because Latin
American Emma's proportionately welfare
programs,
we disproportionately might disagree on
the solution.
Well,
well we're.
I guess we're not moment.
That's right.
So I guess this one,
we're not disagreeing.
You're saying that I'm,
I'm ignoring the fact
that there have been economically
depressed and the economical depression
then leads to higher crime rates.
I agree with all of that.
Okay.
What we disagree on or perhaps what
people disagree with me on a lot are the
solutions for it.
Okay,
and I point out the fact of how we got
here.
If you don't understand how we got here
in terms of buying into the idea that
the government was gonna fix everything,
this victim mentality it is,
and they've been able to sell the
easiest person to sell social.
Some too.
As a wealthy person a go to Hollywood,
they're,
they're like the number one socialist
because they felt guilty about it's
true.
No,
no,
but because they feel guilty about their
wealth,
you,
you are the perfect stereotype of
somebody that I could get to grow
government with Russell.
Look at these poor people.
Look at how well you live.
Look at this podcast studio.
Don't you feel bad as a white,
straight male that all of this is going
on?
Oh,
of course.
Yes.
What should I do?
Use your platform to tell people that
this is wrong and that you,
you become the voice that actually
allows people to grow government.
And what it does is it decreases
opportunities for black Americans
opportunities with me.
That's your normal argument of normal
people.
You're going to have to.
I'm actually just having prefer that
smiling.
Start using that.
There's some rules,
right?
You got me all fired up because I'm not.
I'm like,
I'm not a liberal.
I'm,
if anything,
I'm an east coast into cluster.
I agree with you.
Yeah,
the centralized government.
But where,
where I feel you and I are gonna
disagree is on the level of extending
compassion to give out hugs.
Well,
what do you mean?
How would you,
how would you,
how would you learn it?
Ultimately you order.
How would you give up?
But like,
uh,
but I also want to ask you,
like when your,
what is your solution?
If we both agree that the sort of
centrist left and you can't call those
people come in and you really can't.
Like there's.
So there's,
the difference between them is kind of
negligible between wow,
the difference between the Republicans
and the Democrats is negligible in terms
of like a holistic global philosophy to
inculcate and spread real meaningful
change.
All right.
Uh,
so,
so what,
but you as a conservative,
a believer in conservatism,
what is the solution?
We weren't limited government.
We want free markets and in a society
where people can help.
We've had that.
We've got that now mania.
First off it is working in America.
This is why this is the lowest rate ever
for black unemployment is right now in a
Donald Trump who is allegedly the most
racist president.
If you read the Guardian,
right?
Like he's so racist.
That's so racist.
While he sucks at racism because black
Americans are doing so much better,
there's been a 400 percent increase in
black owned businesses because there's
opportunities.
He's,
he's making sure that there are actually
opportunities.
Do I believe in them?
Yeah.
Those sort of figures when people.
When governments go and we found out
that the unemployment note after Scott,
let me tell you,
let they go 400 percent growth in black
businesses.
You know,
there'll be some state in state
sponsored initiative where you can start
your own business.
Some bullshit thing.
Know that you can't trust them if you
don't.
Hey,
like do you know what?
Like if you'd like a don't believe in
the Democrat Pie,
how can you believe in the Republican
Party differences?
Anybody ever heard me say vote
Republican?
I don't know.
It doesn't have it.
Yeah.
I mean I'm an.
I'm independent.
Okay.
So I,
I vote based on the candidate and the
candidate that I believe in is Donald
Trump.
And let me tell you,
he's neither Republican or Democrat,
which was so interesting to watch you on
the view.
Let me tell you why,
because I've watched you before.
I used to watch your youtube channels
before I even was conservative.
I used to watch all of your thoughts and
I was like,
yeah,
this guy's really smart.
He's really got it.
You understand the problem with the
establishment and.
But what you didn't realize was that
trump was antiestablishment because you
know why you get fooled by wealth.
You think wealth automatically makes you
establishment doesn't obviously he's on
establishment or you wouldn't have the
entire mainstream media on two parties
that were opposing him.
He was the antithesis of all of that.
And he came and he slammed all of it.
Any one.
So I'm a trump supporter and if people
call that trump lickin's like a portion
of the Republican party,
because he had to run on either one
ticket or the other.
He ran as a Republican.
Trump is by no means he calls it the
swamp for a reason.
Do you think that the truly that the
establishment is opposed to trump?
I don't like that.
That media noise and static and Shamash
I,
I agree with you.
I read the stuff about him,
but he is the president of United
States.
And what do you really think he would do
for vulnerable ordinary people?
And do you not think that a certain,
like the commercial and capitalist
society does create huge hierarchies and
pyramids that lead most people?
Not most people.
A significant percentage of the
population to not have access to
sufficient resources and create systems
that are run.
No,
it's not.
If if you're saying to me that because
some person is less driven than me,
I was able to accomplish more and I was
rewarded for it.
That's unfair.
No,
that's not unfair.
As long as we are provided the same
opportunities which in America our
system is.
If you work hard and you're willing to
work hard,
you will be rewarded by system because
some people do.
Capitalism is an economic model that
lifts people out of poverty.
Socialism does it.
It's killed 100 million people in the
last 100 years.
Post capitalism like that.
After they bowed out.
Capitalism like just 10 years ago,
capitalism about the biggest lump of
communism in history.
Lucky it just was completely state
sponsored.
The whole things artificially inflate
your system surviving by the merits that
espouses survival.
You're talking about,
if we're talking about it in 2008,
if we're talking about corruption and
bail,
I don't think they should have been
bailed out.
So yeah,
so I.
I agree with that.
Yeah.
One hundred percent agree with you.
That's exactly right,
because that's not true.
Capitalism,
that,
that wasn't true should have happened
there.
They should have let them go under.
I believe the market.
We've all wasted.
A lot of the people that paid for that.
Baylor had their houses reclaim the have
had their houses foreclosed,
won't get to be angry.
You won't get an argument from me.
Do you think that Donald Trump's going
to address that?
We're going to.
Goldman Sachs was shutting down banks.
We've given these people,
but unfortunately he wasn't the
president have seen now.
And do you think he's not going to get
hit and run on that?
He,
he,
but what he is going to do with
philosophy,
philosophies basically in alignment with
capitalism is what we're talking about.
And that's something that I'm fully
against.
You know,
so,
um,
but I'm talking about your says an
economic model of capitalism is the only
proven model that lifts people out of
poverty,
which is why I agree with that.
But that was about when the banks food.
That's terrible.
Terrible.
Capitalism doesn't do that.
Yes it does.
That's why.
Why do you think America is America?
What made America America?
What you talking about when you say
America,
do you think there is one thing called
America underneath a flag,
like we're like UPI a.
This is America,
the America of poor prenatal.
There's the America of rich people.
There's all sorts of American sorts of
experience of American America.
It is proven that if you make good
choices,
if you stay out of trouble,
if you don't have children out of
wedlock and you have a job,
you will moral code.
That's it and you'll be successful.
That's it.
That's all you have to do,
but in the interim,
you're in a part of a school system that
sells you a thousand ways that you're
being victimized and people as opposed
to going into work are wearing pussy
hats and protesting a fair and
reelection.
I do agree those aspects of the
education system,
they're hugely disempower aganda.
Fair enough.
Like disempowering to ordinary people.
I think we do disagree on some of the
solutions.
Now see,
imagine this like you when you were like
14.
You've got the Anorexia and you don't.
You can't get therapeutic help because
you're too bloody clever.
What do we do in the instance of a,
a,
a woman or go that suffering from
anorexia and it doesn't have your drive.
What happens in this situation?
This is a person.
Wouldn't you agree that requires help,
compassion,
love,
support,
and who do you propose should provide to
that?
Hopefully her parents.
What if her parents,
what do you think the government's going
to just create programs for anorexics to
go to places.
I mean if,
if an anorexic seeks help,
six therapeutical help and they have to
go so bad.
If the government did that,
to me,
it's ridiculous.
It's so ridiculous idea,
but it just depends on bailing out
banks.
Why can't we bail out some anorexia?
Not Bailing out the banks.
The government is not God.
They are not the solution to all your
problems.
Families,
the community,
your friends,
things of that nature.
People forgot about that whole thing.
That happens,
right?
Where like,
where's the girl going to go?
Does she have parents?
Is there anyone before you start
worshiping the government to fix it?
What am I going to do?
I don't have any money in my account.
Is there a government program that will
fix it?
What am I going to do?
I have anorexia is Erica.
This is what's wrong with the world.
People don't remember light before
government was.
I'm astonished by is your belief that
the government is.
He's so friendly.
Benevolence,
go to one that wants to know.
I don't believe in that machine.
Empowering conditioning.
You want to grow it.
You don't walk around with their binders
and they'll do inspection.
Seriously.
You agree with that?
I thought,
that's not my thing.
I don't have polished anorexic programs
for government.
We just created from a list.
We're touching.
Taxis are going up considerably for my
cuddly,
cozy anorexia program and we need a
further 10 percent for little putting
them pie truck epics shut down in the
dumps.
Heroin all day,
but this used to be a thing communities
used to not think.
This individualistic culture is in
itself.
Destroying the principles are spiritual
human level of community.
Do you not think when people see this
economic inequality,
this disparity?
I'm not talking about height in your
little rich friend,
Lola,
Belle or wherever it was.
You went round and see her nanny and
what infuriated by but for,
oh well,
maybe one day I'll have my own nanny.
Do you not think that economic
inequality creates in a human being a
sense of injustice,
of unfairness?
Because people.
Do you know what Kandis that 90 percent
of people that are rich,
do you know why they're rich?
They was born rich.
You're going to tell you something.
I think that economic disparity creates
that feeling,
but at a fundamental understanding of
economics can tell you know that most
people that are rich are born rich.
He's not like there's a tiny minority of
people that are like you that come from
a poor background and managed to
overcome it,
and this is what's a pro I problem.
I've noticed with a lot of great people
is they've sort of belief that their
greatness is something that can be
replicated and I don't think it can.
I see,
so I believe in the individual you don't
believe are differences,
but the primary goal of the individual
should be to serve the community.
I,
I do not believe that the primary goal
of individual fields,
so you're,
you're just,
you're just counting the human spirit.
Now I'm saying that's all there is.
Let me ask you a quick no,
there's not in a humanity.
Think of animals in the wild.
Even have to go to humanity.
We can just think about animals in the
wild.
What is our human instinct?
Okay?
Are you going to make sure that everyone
on this block is fed?
Before you feed yourself?
Do you go around and say,
Hey,
have you had breakfast this morning at
breakfast this morning?
Hey,
how are you going to make sure you're.
And if you have any,
if you have an excess,
of course you're going to do the humans.
Human condition in our incentives are
going to be to want to help you mold
tool one of the richest,
the 15 people on the planet have got as
much cumulative welfare's,
the poorest $5 million,
but your glass.
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
Excuse me.
First and foremost,
you're talking about literally point
zero,
zero.
One percent of the world is what I'm
talking about.
Okay,
and what are they preaching?
What do they want?
Socialism so that nobody else has the
opportunity to become what they've
become.
They're are the ones that are pushing.
Are you kidding?
George Soros doesn't want socialist
policies.
Jeff Bezos is the richest man in the
world,
doesn't want socialist policies.
They want to make sure that no one else
has the opportunity to get to language
because what we do,
here's what my socialism looks like,
tight Jeff Bezos as well from him,
except for a reasonable stipend for him
to live on something that you can have
10 million a year or something,
tax Amazon to the ground so that.
So,
so the rich people pay for 85 percent of
all of the taxes.
You think they should pay for even more?
That's that's fact.
That's fact.
Yes.
Don't tell that's a fact.
The top 10 percent pay for 85 percent of
all the taxes.
When people say they're going to raise
their taxes more,
I'm just like,
how much more should we just say just
pay for all the taxes.
I say I say this,
but there is no.
When you.
You were about to use an example from
the natural world and I'm in.
No,
I was going to say the instinct and when
you're in when you're in the natural
world is that you feed your family
first.
You're not the idea that social goes
against the natural order are we're,
we're in a world of sort of accumulation
and access and I don't think he's even
working.
I wonder about.
So if I want.
Because you could say where do you draw
the line?
Because I'm like,
look at me.
I've got money now.
I'm not poor anymore and I'm not going
right.
I'll just take everything.
That's the thing that I do agree with
when I see you like sort of right wing
commentators talk like they talk about
people that are in a image from the left
and like,
well,
why don't you put some refugees in your
house?
Why don't you give up your money?
And the reason is because people are
selfish and in all of us,
there is a kind of battle between some
of my impulses.
Candice are,
I just want to.
I just want pleasure and fun and I don't
care about anything except myself that's
in me as strong,
but I personally think I don't feel good
when I lived that way.
There are consequences for me and there
were consequences for other others.
So I kind of want to live within systems
that encourage collective and communal
values instead of we're talking about
theft.
Maybe we don't have to go out demanding
that people give up.
Their stuff is theft.
But it sounds pretty.
When you say storage incentives,
now when the government comes in demand
to someone else,
you keep translating what I'm saying.
No,
you're not helping me,
Yo.
He's talking about that.
You're translating what I'm saying into
rhetoric that you can argue with.
Create a straw man of my words as we go.
So you know that that's.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying.
I'm not saying I'm not espousing the
values of big government.
I'm not saying that there's any
political party that currently exists in
any way represents my views.
I'm just asking if in politics,
both personally and collectively,
there's room for a little more
compassionate and love on,
whilst I agree with your,
uh,
the,
that there was something easy to
fetishize about individual achievements
that let in your own case or wherever we
see greatness.
We can't take that example of the
ability of the individual
to overcome adversity to condemn people
that haven't been able to.
But where is there a role then for
compassion and kindness?
I'm not saying there's a big government
and take away from your politics.
So my thing is that the cock of the
conversation could be,
should be completely separate.
Americans give $500,
billion in charity every single year.
Okay?
It has been proven that when you lower
the tax rate,
when you,
when you government stays out of our
paycheck,
we actually give more that we're
inclined to you.
If you have more money and you're able
to do it,
of course you want to give and you want
to help.
When the government is saying,
we're going to tax your business,
if you're successful,
you're going to get taxed more.
What is the incentive for you to want to
jump in?
Build a business?
If you know that you're going to be
penalized for it,
you're going to be penalized for
success.
That's why we believe in limited
government.
I say we obviously I work for an
organization turning point USA.
Well,
it's all about winning banding and
Turning Point USA.
We're launching in the UK,
the UK.
That's what this whole trip is about.
Launching,
turning point and like turning point is
what do you want us to turn to?
We as conservative principles taught in
the school system because the kids are
learning this lolly Dolly,
merry go round.
The world's going to be purple and and
we're all going to have lollipops in the
school systems and then possibly from
your podcasts.
I guess I haven't watched enough
episodes.
I'm the and it's just not.
It's,
it's,
it's the truest,
the,
the economic model of,
of letting people find success because
they're willing to work hard.
If you don't want to work hard,
you shouldn't be rewarded.
I don't believe in that.
I don't believe.
Well,
what about the person doesn't have your
drive or should economic systems govern
the way that we live our lives?
Why is there not room for people to be
different?
Why is he a person who values should be
distilled into what's called the natural
market?
You can't make that go away.
You can't make that go away no matter
what,
in any time in the history of the world
where there hasn't been some give and
some take the you cannot.
You cannot do.
You can't make that go away.
There's no magic wand.
You can wave that's going to make human
incentives and what happens in humanity
go away.
It doesn't matter how rich or how poor
society is.
There's going to be given.
There's going to be take.
People are going to create natural
markets.
Hey,
I have three apples.
I'll give you two apples if you give me
this.
I mean that it just happens.
This is the way the world works.
I appreciate that.
We have certain natural impulses to try
it and to cooperate as opposed to where
you and I are arguing for sypher sleigh
and passionately.
Candice is on the front of a lot.
Firstly,
I disagree with you that there are no
social and economic factors that
contribute,
for example,
to the phenomena of poverty and
persecution of African Americans or
people are like in this country.
I think the experience of being a Muslim
is probably difficult because of the way
Islam is reported about it.
That doesn't mean that,
you know,
I don't see that there's this thing
called terrorism,
but that in itself is somewhat
underwritten by the colonial project.
It's like you sort of deny that history
has happened.
No,
I'm not denying that's happened.
I'm just denying that I live in history.
I don't live in history.
I didn't go to prison.
That's a variant.
This.
This is what people
harp on that and this is why they want
you to focus on this.
When you're in school,
look at what happened.
That's why you're oppressed.
No,
it's not.
Black people were actually outpacing
white Americans in the 19 fifties under
Jim Crow.
In terms of economic growth,
until we implemented the welfare
programs,
we were outpacing them were there were
businesses because our families were
together.
There was the divorce rates isn't what
it was.
People were married.
Our families were together.
We had jobs.
We have starting businesses.
My grandfather did better than my father
did.
Okay.
My grandfather grew up in a segregated
south.
How did he do that?
Because there wasn't all of this crazy
nonsense.
He never took welfare.
There wasn't all this government
regulation.
He started his own business and that is
how you create a successful individual.
My grandfather never ever once
considered himself to be a victim.
He doesn't.
He doesn't think as you play the victim
game.
Anecdotal examples of individual.
I'm not.
I'm not,
but I'm telling you that our system of
government,
I don't think you can realistically
argue that the removal of welfare will
make people go on to become a gauguin
now because I think they're all you can
say because it's not anecdotal.
It's,
it's a fact.
The sign arguing.
If black people were doing better under
Jim crow economically than we're doing
today,
how is that possible?
Explain it to me.
I want to learn.
I think the same way that you're saying
that people have an automatic impulse to
trade.
I think we also have an automatic
impulse to help one another and I think
that what maybe it's happened over the
last,
I don't know,
hundred years perhaps is part of sort of
a post colonial thing is that there's
been such disparity,
such bifurcation of world that there's
like an impoverished class that are
forgotten and I would say the deeply
underserved for me,
I'm not qualified to talk on the issue
of race,
but for me intuitively,
a lot of what you say is God.
I know that some black people were
really offended by it and hurt by and
feel that is a denial.
Why aren't qualified to talk about race?
Because I've had no personal experience
of being a black person.
I've never,
no one's ever used the n word.
Doesn't mean you can't qualify.
Talk about race.
Talk about anything.
Matter of fact,
I mean 90 percent of the things I say
I'm just making up as I go along,
but like,
um,
but my fact is my factories is the same
way that I don't know about other female
experiences.
This is what I know what it's like to
be.
I do know what it's like to feel
oppressed.
I do know it's like to feel,
not heard.
I do know what it's like to feel
vulnerable and I do feel as a person
that can be quite rapacious,
quite greedy,
quite individualistic.
But when I live within systems that
encourage those aspects of my nature by
saying,
look,
you make your own luck in life.
If you're willing to work hard,
you can become anything no matter where
you're from.
In a sense,
my life journey has been that from an
ordinary working class family in Essex,
single parent family,
and now whoop de Doo.
I'm rich,
but that has not left me thinking,
fuck you everyone else.
But it's not like it's so I want,
I want to drive.
I want to drive this point home because
it is.
You used to be more in on the Hollywood
scene in La,
but this is why when these leftist
politicians want to sell these ideas
that are essentially just going to do to
make sure that nobody has an
opportunity,
but everybody's married to the
government,
they turned to Hollywood because it's so
easy to make you feel guilty.
I'm not them guy anymore,
but it's so easy to make people like
you.
You could still say that you're.
You're in the sphere of influencers.
Hollywood influence as you started your
career as an actor,
right?
I mean,
so you could still say it's so easy to
make them feel guilty because most of
them aren't really politically savvy.
They can't have even a discussion that
we're having.
We have no idea what's going on,
but they know that they feel so guilty
about being wealthy that I can come to
you and I can say to you,
feel guilty about being white because
people make them feel guilty.
I'll been welcomed.
They don't understand economics.
They don't realize that they provide
jobs.
Okay.
When Kim Kardashian became Kim
Kardashians,
oh,
should she feel guilty about that?
How many people are now employed because
of the Kardashian Empire?
How many people are employed because of
twitter?
You know,
because Jack Dorsey created twitter and
they feel guilty about it.
Why do you feel you provide
opportunities for people to get jobs?
As human beings,
we should aspire to greater goals than
simply fulfilling a predetermined
economic growth,
but I worshiping continually are the
older of finance we must do better and
we must look for best solution.
I don't know if you do you believe in
God,
right?
And what is it?
Belief in God if it's not a century,
the belief that underneath hatred is
love and underneath the individual is
oneness and that what we do to one
another we do to ourselves and vice
versa,
that we need to create systems that are
reflective of our benevolence.
Kindness.
We don't know if you want to be good and
you want to be benevolent,
you can exercise that in your personal
life as well.
You and I are discussing politics.
What you've done is that you've blended
in your mind that politics and goodness
in oneness,
all she'd go together.
Hell No.
Okay.
There is no such thing as a good
government.
That's why we want it limited.
The idea that government is not going to
become corrupt when you exercise these,
these,
these practices of goodness and the and
that's what they do.
They sell to the public,
we're are going to be good for you and
we're going to extract all of your
dollars and everyone is going to be
equal.
Equally poor.
Incredibly naive thing to say and I'm
startled that you've said it.
The reason that they want government to
be impeded because easier to make money
when there's huge deregulation.
That's why there was the 2008 crash
because the previous 20 years they'd
been loaded.
Loads of the regulation under the
Clinton in her life for me.
You know,
they all,
they all end up in the same basket.
So you're admitting that government is
corrupt and yet you think that
government is solution to solve crime.
Government different.
I'm not talking about God.
You want me to talk to you because I
actually think that,
you know,
because we are seemingly from so far
apart,
there we have an an an odd unity in that
we both agree that government as it
currently exists is a order,
I want to say unacceptable,
ineffective,
negative,
malevolent.
You think the solution is a different
kind of government and you think the
solution is to give you more power to
the already powerful.
I think the government only functioned
as administrative individual branches,
national corporation to the individual.
No,
no.
I never said give more individual,
more powerful individual.
I don't want to give up.
I don't want to give up all of my rights
to a government.
That's arbitrary.
That's going to tell me how to live.
It tells me what to say.
I don't think anyone's gonna take away
your rights.
How could they what?
But what?
I'm interested in,
what I'm interested in,
either of you need to call anybody.
You are enough as you are.
What I'm interested in is what I believe
is the government are the sort of
bureaucratic arm of corporations,
transnational corporations,
and I think like you look at sort of any
government that tries to impose serious
restrictions on the way that Amazon
trade and the way that Amazon are tax
would suffer.
We can't do that in this country.
Like when are you going to win?
There's talk of a sort of a more left
wing government getting into power.
The city's flex his muscles,
everyone starts to brick.
It was like,
you know,
shit themselves to sort of terrified,
right?
So you know,
for me it like a centralized bipartisan.
The Democratic governments as they
currently exist are meaningless and
ineffectual.
I completely agree with you there,
but,
but my concern is,
is that we need to find new ways of
curbing the power of big business.
I'm not talking about some lovely bloody
flourish to making their way in life or
people that are entrepreneurial that is
limited,
but now that's why we like trump is he's
disruptive because he's talking about
it.
We're talking about Google should be
broken up.
It's a monopoly.
I don't agree with monopolies,
right?
Google is a monopoly.
It's a worldwide monopoly.
I have said it vocally a thousand times.
Google should be broken up.
Amazon is prompt,
problematic.
These are things that issues that trump
is tackling and that's why the
establishment with naive as Mark
Zuckerberg,
you know,
testifying these,
he starting to attack this because he
understands that what you're talking
about is real.
The Latin and the right combined.
Right?
Um,
and,
and that's why I say I'm not a
Republican.
I don't want to be associated with the
swamp Republicans.
I'm a or have a leftist who pretend that
they're,
you know,
they care about people,
but in reality of this extracting
dollars and power for themselves as they
grow government to make sure that just
the bureaucrats enrich their pockets.
That's what trump is disrupting.
It's hard for people to process that
because trump is wealthy,
but that is what he's doing.
I mean,
if you look at every policy he's made in
terms of all the activities implemented,
that is why there is a war on him and
all out war in terms of the media.
The same is happening in other
countries,
you sort of populist movements are
starting to arise.
Um,
and I support them in Italy and Brazil
look like most people who are wealthy
because the vagina that he emerged from,
and then he did very well on top of
that.
So I mean to describe what he's done,
what he's built is,
is not good.
You know,
he hasn't been paying and just maintain
fail before they find success.
You really like him,
but most people fail because this is,
this is what I don't like either people
say because you fail.
No,
it's pretty funny.
He's hilarious.
I mean,
if the people that can enjoy trump,
I feel bad for that means he's pointedly
hilarious.
He says things that everybody's thinking
and it's calling out people that have
been impossibly corrupt.
We're going to say lock her up.
Hillary should be in prison.
Most Americans feel that way.
What she did to Haiti alone,
what the Clinton Foundation did to Haiti
alone,
they should all be locked out.
I'm no fan of the Clintons.
I'll tell you that now.
He had the balls to say it.
What
politician?
Everybody else's,
oh,
but it's the Clinton.
That's the dynasty in the bushes.
It's,
you know,
we can't say these things.
Trump just says it.
They're all corrupt.
So you liked that you liked these as
sort of a rabble rouser.
But the thing that I would concern me is
that I feel that our,
um,
social systems will need to look beyond
terrible handouts.
I wonder it world where sort of your
ideology was realized as I'm starting to
understand as I listened to you,
like the,
the sort of the individual,
uh,
on impeded unimpaired reaching for
Nietzschean glory.
What happens to people that are not in
Dow with the facilities to achieve that?
Because some,
we are existing on a spectrum as you
say.
Some people just need a bit of help and
a bit of love to tell the truth.
If I hadn't been helped again to a
treatment center,
I think I'll still be on drugs.
If I didn't have other people helping me
to stay clean one day at a time,
I think I might relapse.
I'm held invisibly,
held by relationships with people that
are kind and compassionate to me.
And if it wasn't presented as if the
government shrinks as your friend just
got out the government though,
although you just set that someone's
going to have to break up these
monopolies and I don't know,
you think it's going to do that.
Goldman Sachs government,
that's what this company,
our country was founded upon.
Just accidentally call it a company.
I'm sorry we're keeping the best company
in the world.
But like,
you know,
Britain was essentially just the sort of
a front for the colonizing powers of the
east India tea company.
And I believe in limited government that
I believe that government should come
because we learned from,
uh,
you know,
the 19th,
late,
late 19th century,
early,
early 20th century that once if
businesses run and they'll eventually
create monopolies.
And that's what we're seeing,
I think happened with Google and the
function of the government is to protect
us against that so that there's
opportunities for the little guy and
small businesses to get in and to
compete with these bigger companies.
Um,
so I,
I can ever work on a global level now
with sort of the way that trade operates
and with,
and with there being such powerful
monoliths already in place.
Will those powers ever yield any of
their potency?
What would make it Google?
Um,
as in the silicon valley giants,
the,
the Energy John.
So the forces that we know we're behind
the sort of the recent Middle East and
oil wars.
What will make those companies you to
some of their power,
what would do that?
What force could oppose that?
Only the people and under what banner to
the People Unite.
It's like you try to,
it feels to me that you're taking away
the hmm.
The capacity for human beings to unite
under by don't agree with divisive
policy of your,
this gender,
your,
that color.
I think we are one and we should look
for ways to find common connections.
I've got more,
probably more in common with you even
though there's so much different about
us politically and believing in that.
We're both mouthy individually.
That's exactly right.
And I agree with that and I think that
that's important discussion to have,
but when I,
in terms of how I use my voice
and what I'm talking about,
I'm in the realm of politics and I
don't.
I think that the problem is,
is that people want to insert compassion
into the political realm too much.
You know,
just management will,
is politics is not about helping human
beings to gain access to resources.
It's,
I really think that the what,
what should be the function of a
politician?
What do you think that you told me
you're the bloody expert.
I mean they're supposed to go and what
should it be?
Right?
I mean,
I think it's gotten to the point now
that it just becomes about them trying
to enrich their own pocket.
Should it be.
I think it should be.
They are there to protect the rights of
the people that have already been
established.
You know,
that they are supposed to be
representing their constituents,
the people that were all bloody bloody
established.
What about people that need help?
Making sure that their rights are
protected,
that they're able to create an ad,
that they have opportunities and the
idea that you can,
that they'll still have opportunities if
you grow government is.
It hasn't been so many times nothing.
It's killed 100 million people in the
last 100 years.
It's,
it's,
it's jarring to me that we have people
that are running around saying that it's
good again,
especially in Europe.
I mean,
you guys really should understand that
social doesn't work.
I mean like really like what is it going
to take for your.
How many times did we have to get the
phone call and America,
Hey,
you dare doing again.
You will let this run because we're
like,
really?
Guys,
again,
we're doing it again.
Like,
no,
it's different.
This is different.
Jeremy Corbyn's like a democratic
socialist who says a lot of antisemitic
things,
you know,
it's like,
really?
How many times do you guys have to.
What's it gonna take for you guys to
learn your lesson?
I mean,
that's how I feel,
at least in America and I love my
breasts.
Look,
we,
we fight.
We ended the wars together so that,
I mean,
that's why we're doing tpu kegs.
It's like,
all right,
it's getting a little crazy again.
Might have to step in and start some
normal conservative principles again
into the dialogue because we've got it.
It's gone crazy.
The socialist,
it doesn't work on crazy.
There is no.
There is no meaningful socialism at any
level of power.
Anyway.
Let's see.
Where was it?
What do you.
What do you mean?
Anywhere?
Venezuela.
What do you mean?
There's no.
No.
Always banging on about 15 people live
there.
Don't you dare come to the United
States.
They're United States.
You know,
the average citizen has last April.
Have an over here.
You guys should like put me finish
whitelaw.
I'm the Venezuelan people.
I don't think the social,
the experiments with socialism in a very
common in Venezuela or having any
meaningful impact on the American
economy or the global economy or global
or geopolitical power structures.
So what I'm interested in is my friend.
Why all this macron fascist.
He's a total.
No,
no,
he's a global list.
He's on.
He's on a fascist.
The globalist.
Okay.
And,
and,
and all of the people that stood up and
said awful things about trump are now
realizing that everything that he was
saying was essentially right,
you know,
and his people think about what's going
on in,
is fascinating.
The far left and the far right are
together rioting in the streets.
I love that.
Think about that and why?
Because of these things,
like what was the tipping point?
They were hiking prices to protect the
environment.
Again,
they,
they're going to tell you that they're
doing something to protect you,
but extracting,
finding fun ways to extract dollars.
Now there is no jobs and people are
unemployed.
Every ones on welfare and government
programs and on top of that.
So you asked what happens in socialism
every single time she met kronas
associates,
which is just bizarre to me because he's
a former social.
France has been proliferating a welfare
state since the 19 seventies.
Okay.
And that's what it is.
There are people don't work in French.
They're lazy.
And that's what happens in a socialist
model.
Everyone becomes lazy because you're
going to say,
if you become Richmond attacks you with,
why the hell am I going to work all,
sit back and wait for the government to
give us handouts.
Oh wait,
that can't happen because now there's no
one left.
The tax.
Everybody's equally.
You guys are right.
Socialism does call poverty crime base
for socialism.
If you want equality,
they will.
They reasonable
what?
Look,
I've been a bit Glib and a bit silly at
several points during this conversation
because I find you very charming and
interesting to talk to,
but I must say in all seriousness that
you cannot cite any of these countries
as examples of socialism or socialism's
of failures because they.
Because macron is existing with
comfortably within the framework of the
kind of neo,
neo liberal failings that are bringing
about the current mass discontentment
that has brought about brexit and trump
and I think that neither brexit nor
trump will address or eight ordinary
people.
One Jot.
Not that I disagree with people who are
voting for Brexit or for voting for
trump because I agree with them that
things weren't going well for ordinary
people and I understand their
dissatisfaction,
but what I don't see how the solution to
the problems of ordinary people will
ever be to give more power to the
already powerful.
I wouldn't confront you hugely over the
government.
I think you and I both do not trust
I'm,
I'm beginning to work out where people
from the left and where they can,
uh,
collaborate,
collude and agree.
But obviously the,
the main problem for me is that I feel
that all politics ultimately has to be
an expression of human goodness.
And whilst it is ultimately about
pragmatism,
what is the point in being pragmatic?
If we're not symbol timelessly,
being loving and beautiful,
what is our aim?
What is the optimum?
What are we trying to achieve?
And surely that must be a fair and just
world where the brilliant get to thrive
and the vulnerable are loved and taken
care of.
A shaming that there are still
categories such as the vulnerable and
the brilliance.
I love everything you said is it sounds
totally utopia,
but it's just not pragmatic.
Well,
that's what people say.
It is.
Not Conservative.
Can created government for me right now.
What are you going to do?
Oh,
let's do it.
Let's do it right now.
No,
I mean seriously,
because this is how.
This is how socialism gets sold because
it sounds good.
Hey,
but that is a socialist socialist pitch.
That's that's what they be socialist,
right?
Amount.
Saying the Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez.
I just want a world where everybody,
the minimum wage is $30 an hour and I
don't know who's going to pay for it.
Doesn't matter.
We're going to talk practically.
It's going to feel good.
We're going to just tax the rich and
we're going to take from this person.
You can only take from the rich for so
much.
Essentially what you have to focus on is
creating opportunities for every single
person to become rich,
systemic inequality and a massive
philosophical disjunct in the fact that
when there was,
when all these systems,
these systems that you say are going to
take care of us,
they're going to create trickle down
wealth,
but when they did ultimately inevitably
fail,
they would,
but when they do fail,
they are bailed out by the people.
That's the people,
ordinary people,
so why should I trust those?
Shouldn't,
but why don't you keep telling us that
we should grow government.
I'm not telling you to centralization.
I do think that we need programs to help
people know what I'm thinking.
The words are coming.
Let's do it.
We're building your community.
Okay,
but that's your position.
That's a conservative position.
We're saying all of these programs,
entities might need some assistance to
you.
I think you just don't realize that
you're a conservative.
Listen,
you are a conservative because you were.
You're identifying the same problems and
you're agreeing the solution not be more
candidates,
but you've backed socialist candidates,
which makes no sense.
Everything lines up biggest trouble.
I go and we're saying,
oh,
don't vote for anyone because I think
it's all total bullshit and it ends with
the power ends up in the hands of the
same people anyway,
and it was as if I kicked the football,
it really prime minister,
the Guardian,
The Guardian as a matter of fact shot
and were probably the worst job that
sort of changed their propaganda.
Yeah,
they're just literally propaganda by
finger that,
but why I would say that the differences
between some of these things that we're
arguing about,
the distinctions are negligible.
I think that what's required is a kind
of radicalism,
radical change,
but what makes me nervous about some of
the stuff you say candice,
is it's kind of lack of empathy.
I can't help but see that teenage girl
with Anorexia not being treated with
love and care and nurture.
What?
That you get what I'm saying.
Does that make it more likely that
people feel loving and compassionate?
I don't think that's the role of the
government.
I think that's the role of the family.
So if we were.
This is not about politics and we
started
talking about posting done raising kids,
but I was so compassionate.
Industrial post technological capitalist
societies.
The family is no longer an all powerful
unit.
There is already such massive
inequality.
I'm not.
I'm not clever enough to argue with you
about whether or not big government
centralization is problematic as you
say,
but what I do know is unimpeded
capitalist power is the biggest
contribution to the problems we have in
the world.
Okay?
Actually no,
so socialism has has killed.
It's not capitalism killed 100.
We don't know.
It was harder to.
Harder to curate the information.
We don't know how many people are killed
in the various colonial wars that
America has been engaged with ever since
the Second World War.
All of those economic,
close ideological component of that is
because,
and,
and I will agree with you here,
the idea that you're going to go and you
don't have natural resources because I
don't know,
environment environmentally friendly.
Kids don't want you to do fracking or
whatever it is,
and then you go and you say,
well,
here's an oil rich country and we're
going to go and we're going to invade
it.
We're going to take things over.
I disagree.
I disagree with all of that,
so it'd be an Itam has got to be the
aim.
You can't be seriously saying that Islam
should be the aim.
Did you just shouldn't be.
That shouldn't be the.
I literally like like that.
Well,
I will also be the place where we all
can't happen.
It can't happen.
Human beings are always going to.
I've since the,
since biblical times,
there are always going to battle.
The point of the Bible is that we will
transcend that.
A man will transcend.
Here.
We can get beyond that.
Primal desires,
our primal desires that you're trying to
turn into systems,
greed,
jealousy,
conservatism.
No,
no,
no.
It's the opposite.
I'm saying you have to acknowledge that
this exists.
This is why it's foolish when people
gave up all of your and then what
happens?
What happened to Venezuela when they get
up all the rights and they sold them
this utopian concept that Russell brand
loves and there's going to be flowers
and Venezuela and skittles and we're all
going to go to Willy Wonka everyday
because what happened?
Oh,
we found out what happens when you give
all your money,
the government,
the government keeps it found in
medicine.
Well,
because you know why?
Because the government is governed by
human beings and human beings are greedy
or you know,
if you're a terrible human being,
but when you give them all of your
money,
you're going to see what happens in
times.
Individuals,
candice,
these untrammeled individuals that have
gotten no regulation,
well,
they're going to be different from the
Venezuelan government aid government
where they,
when their incentives are not to go line
their own pockets and government and
know that they have term limits and that
they literally are there to serve the
people.
Okay,
interesting.
Then allow them to do their damn job and
look at these companies and say,
is this now but not Napoli?
Yes,
it is.
Break up Google will that we agree on
that as well.
As long as it still works,
because I do need it mostly for my own
name.
Now.
I just need a search engine called the
Russell brand search engine that be
enough for me.
As long as I have that,
you can break up that monopoly.
Candice,
there's another thing I'm going to ask
you.
That thing you just said mate,
about like a human beings are greedy and
cruel and components of humanity.
Here were.
You said that that's huge for me.
When you said that.
I thought it was very telling.
I feel that that is ultimately what you
believe.
I think human beings are vocally.
I do think that first time,
what do you think?
First off human beings do you.
I'll ask you a question.
Do you think were more good or more
evil?
Good.
I think human beings are beautiful.
What do you think were born?
Pure and good and wonderful.
You have a small child as soaps and
teach human beings.
Good.
Listen,
the culture is definitely a factor,
but this is my point.
You've asked me a question.
Please allow me to out sultanates and
says the line between good and evil
runs,
not through nations,
religions or creeds,
but through every human heart,
because I know that there is darkness in
me.
I know there is selfishness and greed
and and like Libido,
life force,
not necessarily a bad thing,
but last,
for example,
I know all these things exist in me,
so I need to exist within communities
and systems that acknowledge that I am
flawed and that I can fail,
but encourage the better parts of my
nature.
For me,
that is not a kind of Venal,
economically driven system that rewards
kind of the pursuit of excess.
We can.
I don't think we can ever be fulfilled
by commodity.
through acquisition.
I think that our goals must become
spiritual,
but I agree with that.
I'm not in favor of creating banal
Stalinist,
a massacre factories,
but I also resent and reject the
illusion of a commercial capitalist
state where people are being underserved
spiritually.
People are neglected and cut off and
below.
Oh,
drew Loki.
We're with them.
We've ever been statistically things
that Upi,
well,
I live in this world and I feel a lot of
dissatisfaction,
a lot of pain.
I've been rich,
I've been poor,
I've been in both of those worlds and I
sense that there is something spiritual
that is not being served,
that is being neglected and I feel a
huge part of that is living in a world
where the supreme ideals are
economically driven,
where there is a huge unfairness,
where we are ignoring the problems of
the earth and to hear you talk about a
sort of fracking and like in it simply
because it is another way of serving
conservative or capitalist goals.
That concerns me.
Well not I brought it up because you
brought up the Middle East and the
conquest that we're going over there
because he wanted their conservatism
used to be about conserve the planet.
First and foremost.
You've got to live on it.
I don't think that in America it
concerned me.
It means used to be supply about
conserving.
We've got to look after the care a
little more about the environment here
than in America.
We have the like obviously the
environmentalist,
but I think probably stronger here I've
noticed.
I'm not saying there's one way one is
wrong or one is
right.
I'm just making a note here.
How could we.
What you're talking about is that you
think that all that exists is politics.
Take Yoga class.
You want some spiritual balance after
you go to work or you go take a yoga
class.
You had the money to do that.
Um,
to go.
Do you sit and do Koombaya and do all of
that stuff.
I like it all.
Family.
It's not cynical,
but I really,
I like getting from Yoga.
I Love Yoga.
I love spiritualism.
I told you I originally found you
because you were talking about
spiritualism.
I was like on Youtube and I remember
just being very granted would show was
never seen that show before.
But you were talking about spiritual
fulfillment and I agree with you on all
of those things.
Where we disagree is that you don't seem
to think that both of those can live at
the same time.
Like if capitalism exists in
spiritualism,
die,
it's.
No,
it doesn't.
You can be spiritual and you can let
capitalism you like it.
A capitalist says,
I like.
I like switches from so much I'm going
to open a yoga studio.
Know that is turning everything into a
commodity like ultimate end of
everything is to turn and I'm guilty of
this.
As soon as I like genuine,
I'm the kind of person.
I make up a beautiful song from my door
and Oh my God,
I should write a children's book about
this.
I have that interesting.
I am an entrepreneurial person.
I am an individualist,
but I feel that these impulses in me
kind of be better utilized if they are
in the service of others,
so then share it.
That's what I do.
I get spiritual fulfillment when,
when,
when black kids from the ghettos and and
the hood,
right?
To me and say thank you so much.
Finding your perspective has transformed
my life.
Right?
And they say,
because I just put out something that I
genuinely believe in and it's backed in
my heart and it's back to my spirit.
Now what fulfills you might be something
different,
but you determining that what people
should like and what should dry you
know,
what fulfills that are,
what should be compassionate.
That's that.
Those are words that are subjective.
They're not objective.
It's subjective.
I think that's true and I think I can
understand why a young black children
would be inspired by a powerful woman
like you who communicates brilliantly
and is so strong and successful,
but I would imagine it may be
disheartening to hear you disavow the
impact of social historical and cultural
influences on the plight of individuals
and individual families to extract that.
I think he's cool,
but I don't talk about it all the time
doing it.
You're condemning people in saying that
the individual is in charge of their own
destiny.
You are.
You are in the shadow of that is people
that are responsibility of to blame.
Yeah.
No,
I.
I truly believe if people wake up and
they understand that they even control
their own destiny,
that they can,
they will be in control of.
That is a good point.
I think that's a good point,
but I do also agree that that is the
obligation of all of us to be careful,
protect,
reach out to one another and I feel like
I'm concerned by that.
I'm concerned that you feel that because
it's sort of like for me,
where is the love?
What do you mean there's,
there's love.
In my personal life,
I don't feel bad for people that are
lazy and looking for excuses.
So if that sounds,
if that feels like.
And that's like,
hold on,
let's get to the course.
I figure most people are lazy.
Okay.
Much.
Right?
Yeah,
there you go,
brother.
Get success and then you know what?
When you get to a certain age and you
realize you have accomplished nothing or
drove and all of a sudden you became.
I mean say,
but most people are lazy.
It's true.
I'd rather be in bed sleeping sometimes
when I get up and I do stop because I
realized I have to be different,
but here's the thing.
You asked telling me what I have to
extra eyes compassionate.
Understanding how people are lazy
because they woke up one day and they're
27,
they realize you have accomplished
nothing,
so they turned to videos that tell them
that it's not their fault,
it's somebody else's.
It's the white man.
It's the rich man.
It's the tall man.
It's the short man,
right?
I don't care about any of that.
I am telling you that personal
responsibility is really the key to
unlocking light.
CanNot deny things that happened and did
you exercise compassion in those
moments?
That's why I give to charity,
right?
It's not going to be enough because by
taking the lazy people in my home,
I've already got a cat.
She's pretty fucking lazy because what
I'm saying is this.
What am I saying?
What are you saying to me?
So I'm saying to you that you are
misusing your power,
that you should be using your power to
bring other people up.
That's what I'm doing.
And I feel that to deny that there,
that there is economic disparity.
The racial inequality is part of the
story,
but historically there has been a
component of the male oppression of a
female.
I don't.
I agree with that.
I agree that the world puts.
You're talking about our stories
individually agree with.
We're agreeing everything that you just.
I don't deny.
I acknowledged that there's economic
disparity because I tell them everyday
the reasons why is why I teach them.
There's economic disparity.
Don't be so foolish to believe it's
because your skin is black.
It's because we are disproportionately
taking handouts from the government.
We are disproportionately marriage the
government,
and we have bought into our own victim
mentality.
Okay,
because we're taking advice from fucking
Lebron James about politics and voting
in people that want to do harm to the
black community.
Plan.
Simple.
Most people don't even know their own
history.
You sit down and and you have black
people that are advocating for planned
parenthood and nobody's talking about
the quiet black genocide that's taking
place in America right now because our
birth rate has completely stagnated and
we're the only ones.
Sixty one percent of all new brush
Latino.
So in the Democrats say open borders,
open borders.
What they're really saying is boats,
boats,
because the black people are not gonna.
Be able to stay in our party much
longer,
so let them know that planned parenthood
was created by an avowed racist,
Margaret Sanger who said that her
purpose was to exterminate the black
race.
She said,
black people should be exterminated like
weeds.
Most bucket don't know that,
and yet they go out and they say
conservatives are crazy because they
want to defund planned parenthood
defunded because the black,
the black birth rate has has stagnated.
Okay,
so I'm actually all about black and
power,
which is why when people actually find
me long former listened to
what I say,
it clicks and they say,
oh my God,
and then they researched Margaret sanger
and then they researched that,
the black birth rate,
and they realize that we have literally
we are paying politicians taking the to
tear apart our families and it makes
sure that we don't have a place in
America.
I look,
I agree with some of the things that you
are saying,
but what I don't understand is how this
information can neatly absolves or
resolve itself at the point of a much
wider.
Donald trump's a good thing that's
crazy.
So easily illusion,
so easy.
It's so easy.
That's how I got into this because
because Donald Trump was a thing,
Donald Trump has done more for the black
community then.
Then certainly any of the predecessor
Democrat presidents had done beforehand.
You know,
you have Bill Clinton who was held as a
black presidential hero,
but first black president is what they
called Bill Clinton.
He also locked up more black men than
any president in the history of the
United States.
That's a fact.
He put in place with three strikes,
laws.
That's a fact.
Um,
and then you have lbj hailed as a hero
in our textbooks.
He's the one that implemented the
welfare state and he called her the
nigger bill.
You know,
he,
he literally called,
uh,
the civil rights act,
the nigger belt bucket,
but don't know that now it's all
available on the Internet.
So they're,
all they have to do is hear what I say.
And they'll do that after they watch
this podcast and do research and they
go,
why is it,
why is the education system lying to me?
Why do I think Bill Clinton's a good
person?
After what he did to Haiti,
and I don't disagree with you,
I mean like I think more broadly,
I can see how you meet a lot of your
goals by condemning apparently left
centrist politicians who I remember I've
already told you I don't see the
distinction between left and right
within the limited framework of
conventional political.
That's fair as a,
uh,
as,
as meaningful.
Yeah.
Go and have some stuff to eat.
The perhaps perhaps perhaps the problem
is actually that you're hungry.
Was Secretary happened because a hungry
person who's taking it out on most
vulnerable members of society and the
black community and the black community
for synchronous.
Now you sound like every leftist
politician script.
I'm empowering for black people.
All they have to do is listen.
The
goal of your empowerment,
it ends in a sort of a rather unpleasant
individualistic message that leaves
behind that doesn't include the
possibility that some people's social
history and personal history has left
them impaired and unable to compete in a
system but prizes,
certain assets,
certain personal attributes above
others.
None of us like that.
We need a culture that can accommodate
all people because all people exist and
all people do have rights and if you
like,
whilst I feel like you know,
I can see the logic in,
you know,
or what you're saying about I'm like,
the patriarchy stuff and all that.
All you need to do is all we need to do
is quickly look at who has the most
wealth,
who has the most power,
who has the most influence that day
areas available.
Like something like that.
You know when you say if like s like 15
people have
as much wealth as the poorest 5 billion
people.
That's not minor.
That's a serious systemic problem.
We could solve a great many problems by
simply removing and redistribute in that
wealth,
but even that's not enough.
I'm undergrad changing systems more
broadly where we do agree hugely as on
decentralization and the breakup of
monopolies.
But what I think is the biggest
distinction you and I have is your
belief that people are governed by
selfish,
selfish impulses and my belief that
people are ultimately good and that we
should create systems and communities
and values that encourage our virtue
rather than usher us subtly towards
either nihilism or selfishness,
and I think that that's what you are
doing better than that.
I'm preventing people from falling into
your logic because the easiest people to
take advantage of people that believe
what you believe,
because then all they do is to take
somebody like George Soros or Jeff Bezos
to say,
this is why they want socialism because
it says all of you guys,
you're going to stay poor,
but we're going to sell to you that
we're going to fix all your problems.
You're going to get all of your rights
to us,
and that's what happens.
That's what happens every single time.
Realized that within a system that has
limited resources available to become
rich anyway,
you think there's finite resources.
What?
On a finite planet?
Yes.
No,
no,
but like at once starting,
people are and nobody else can get rich
because that's wrong.
Hold on a second then.
Why do you not believe you don't believe
that there's a stagnation in stacy's in
where wealth is accumulated and where
wealth is held.
Do you not see that there are a dentist?
If you're buying into the myth that
because somebody got rich,
somebody else got poor and that's wrong
because somebody got rich multiples,
perhaps our job because somebody got,
which does not mean that a bunch of
other people got poor.
That is a fallacy and it is.
No,
that's just pulled back when Jack Dorsey
of twitter got rich,
all of his employees got poor and note
they became employees of twitter,
facebook employees.
I'm a ton of people all around the world
because they're facebook now.
Are they always register?
Mark Zuckerberg?
No,
but they were given opportunities to get
their foot in the door at a tech company
and it put facebook on their resume pro.
The old capitalism.
I notice candice is.
I listened to you.
Big Secret.
I'm Amazon,
right?
So listen,
here's the,
uh,
there's,
the world is limited.
It's only that big.
There are people on the world,
only a tiny number of people have got
most of the wealth and asset.
Oh,
if some of it will trickle down to the
others,
that's that the,
the idea that I did not work out,
your people are keeping that wealth and
not letting it trickle down,
sticking people in prison because there
are these brilliantly economic.
How do you extract well from wealthy
people?
Take it.
See that?
That's your problem.
That's theft.
No competition,
free markets,
building a product that's better than
facebook to this,
that would lead to.
So what led to this mobilism in which
something that I am staunchly against
and I speak out about all the time,
don't agree with globalism.
Globalism is a bunch of elitist.
Fighting themselves and saying,
wait a second.
How much power we control now that can
make sure that we're the only ones that
maintain more regulation.
That's more government.
No,
it's not.
It's the function of government to make
sure that that doesn't happen.
Limited government.
That is literally why we started putting
in place these policies in America.
If the government hasn't happened,
listened to finish,
being able to run without a government,
both literally eating food now all over
the microphone.
If the government,
so that we currently have on able to
curb or in any way control corporate
power,
how is less government going to do that
more effectively or less government
busters to fight you.
And when I'm saying limited government,
so the idea that growing welfare
programs and trying to extract wealth
from the rich,
it's just,
it's not gonna work that's not,
that doesn't work over time because that
if you want to talk about a finite
resource,
there's only so much money you can bleed
out of rich people.
Um,
and,
and that's,
and it never happens that way by the
way.
They take money from the rich and they
enrich themselves.
The government gets bigger,
the government gets Richard and people
get poor.
That is what the history of the world
taught us.
Some things to be annoying,
you know,
because it's true,
Cuba,
you know all,
you know what happened in the Soviet
Union,
you know what happened in Cuba,
you know what's happening in Venezuela,
you know that social and doesn't work
and get your,
your teaching or having your stroke,
but you are,
you're just not calling it socialism.
That's what you're talking about.
We can't give.
What is the new system.
You're either going to grow government
or you're going to grow the individual.
No,
there's no.
That's not the only option.
Oh,
Gimme.
GimMe Gimme.
Another option.
I think de-centralized collectivized
communities,
a confederacy of principled,
cooperating,
fully autonomous self governing
communities that might require to some
degree,
some ability to tax regulate and
control.
Certainly the kind of transnational
monoliths that we tax to the government.
I don't know,
but what's the problem?
But.
But hold on a second,
you can't like get all like me because I
have.
I'm not able to immediately designed a
new system.
It's not immediately.
You've been doing this for awhile and
when I listen to,
it's not the first time you've had this
conversation.
You're either you,
you want to play it both ways,
so you want to say I believe in the
community,
but the community should tax.
Okay,
so the community should be a government
website and let's try and see if we can
work out together because if it's not
good,
we just simply won't you because he's a
bit of the podcast.
We're going to use all of it.
People need to know we are building a
government thing,
right?
Just say it,
Say we like take for example,
now we've had brexit.
Britain could be an independent unit if
I agree that we decentralized government
power because it is meaningless and it
doesn't serve ordinary people.
However,
what we need people do.
Some people,
a lot of people it seems to want jobs
and they want to be meaningfully paid
for those jobs.
Some people that I think are not paid
enough money,
police,
nurses,
teachers,
none of these people are paid enough for
what they do.
That's because of the unions.
That's because the government.
Oh yeah,
the LG unions and the government allow
us to fire fire,
bad teachers bringing negative things in
there.
You're white bringing negative energy.
It's true.
The government is is the reason for that
now differently in this new utopia that
we're trying to create.
It wouldn't.
Your gender,
religion,
and race would be irrelevant to you?
You'd be free to practice whatever.
It's foolish.
I already don't have this government.
That's insane.
Hold on.
Maybe the government is not done
anything yet.
This is ridiculous.
What's ridiculous?
Let me ask you a question.
Actually a very good question.
Most of you offset those talks to you.
No.
Okay.
Listen,
Paul wrote the myth of Co a.
that's a loaded question.
Do you believe in multiculturalism?
Do I believe that there are many
cultures that they can just exist,
coexist peacefully?
I think that there are many cultures
think that they can exist.
I think we're two people in a room and
it's a problem,
so of course there's going to be
conflict if people have got different
belief systems.
However,
we cost like,
Yo,
right,
hold on a minute,
so you want total deregulation of bloody
capitalists,
but when it comes to what people want
book people read when they're praying,
oh,
suddenly,
suddenly there is a regulation.
You can be whatever religion you want to
be an American.
There's no regulation on that,
but what I'm saying she was,
do you believe that that mold,
multiple cultures can coexist peacefully
because that's it.
That's a.
that's a huge problem.
What do you believe in then secretary?
I believe that the biggest problem
facing Europe right now is the is the
mass migration from countries that do
not support the culture of Europe.
Right?
Look,
shut up.
Let's talk about some.
All right.
Good.
To talk about some positive thing.
Trying to create a utopia or over here
in this thing,
in this new,
this new Britain that we're trying to
create on my ipad.
It doesn't matter what your gender is or
how you identify.
It doesn't matter what color you are and
it doesn't matter what your religion is.
You can't buy.
You cannot impose your will on other
people.
You can't go around saying you,
but you should believe this or you
shouldn't believe that.
You've got to leave people a hell alone.
Right?
It doesn't work.
It doesn't yell.
Component of Sharia law is that people
that are non believers get killed.
Hold on a second.
I didn't say we will help you.
We want Sharia law.
I'm not bringing in Sharia law.
That's not.
We're not having met on the island.
It sounds terrifying,
right?
Bomb this sharia.
Now what we're gonna do on the island
now,
he said,
people can be fully there,
fully autonomous.
They can do what they want.
Now.
I suppose we are going to have to have
communities now.
I think it might be hard for human
beings to live in communities that are
too big.
I think many of the problems that we're
experiencing now is it's hard for us to
hold the number of relationships we see.
Too much variety of life is confusing
for people.
I think we need to live in smaller
communities and within these
communities,
these units,
these,
let's call them Soviet people.
People have full a full democracy within
it.
People vote on how they want their
resources as happened.
Importantly,
agree Brazil,
you vote on like say each community is
allocated a budget and the members of
that community vote for how to spend
that budget.
Okay.
Right.
That's good.
So far we do need some municipal
resources,
IEA,
roads,
Agri police officers,
fire malaise,
fireman and nurses.
All of those.
So that revenue has got to come from
somewhere.
Private business world isn't gas attacks
I'm comfortable with because it's for
municipalities and that's the difference
between not theft and something that I
get to use.
So I need it now.
Do wheat right now.
Are we gonna?
Need some kind of.
Because people are going to be jealous
of this.
They're going to want to come and live
here with us.
We're going to identify how are we going
to control the population we have here,
right?
We're going to need to know,
Okay.
We good?
We can just like we're not building,
we're an island.
We're surrounded by a moat already.
Look,
what I'm saying is that there are so
many unexplored possibilities and um,
people on both the left and right and
I've got those I spoke to,
enough of them now impede further debate
and progressing by insisting that their
preexisting ideology is the only thing
that could possibly work as if history
were rich enough and long enough that
blinking of an eye,
the expanding of one flower,
the issue manatee were enough to examine
all possibilities.
Now me,
all that stuff you say is wooly wishy
washy left the crowd.
Clap trap is mere pragmatism.
The experience of being human is painful
enough without us being cruel to one
another.
We need to live in communities where
people are infested and administrative
and certainly our democratic level in
the way that their resources are spent
and the way their communities are run,
the way their schools around the way
their hospitals around full
democratization.
So that's what I'm arguing for.
So everything that you just drew is
America.
The founding,
the founding principles of America is
what you just do.
And that's what conservatives fight for.
I'm going to against it that you are
conservative.
You just haven't acknowledged it yet.
I'm not concerned.
You don't realize it.
I'm just going to say that you're an
anarchist and you don't acknowledge it,
but because you want to break down all
power structures and you think that
people want the government where you
just wrote municipalities,
that's the function of government.
The government should make sure that
those programs run efficiently,
that that,
that we have access to other people are
paving roads and that sort of a thing.
The,
the infrastructure,
all of that is an important thing.
I think might bust up your conservative
thing,
but,
but our priorities are not commerce.
Our priorities are creating a nourishing
the communities that we live in
supporting and loving one another,
so according to each,
according to their needs,
that commerce that is common,
this call it community ism is community
is we make the community the most
important thing and the w.
What the community has to do is empower
the individual and love the individual
and acknowledged that we in our history
of colonization and war,
we have hurt and damaged one another and
people are carrying trauma and pain from
like your anorexia and racial abuse is
another lesson for me are prime examples
of exactly that and it to you for the
way that you have alchemize that into
individual potency,
but I don't think we should be getting
off the train too early.
Why set the bar so low for humankind?
Not only are we not victims,
we can be glorious.
We are not determined by our lower
instincts and the lower aspects of our
nature.
We can continue to grow.
Continue to aspire.
The thing is is that when I asked you to
draw it out,
your drawing systems that already exist,
but to create anything new and so we
can't look good,
but we can look back into the history
and see how it worked out.
Communism.
Now hold on.
I'm not drawing things that.
Hold a sec.
Mao was hardly.
Decentralist was so serious.
Centralized power and bureaucracy.
No,
but he raised that uprising that you're
talking about the proletariat versus the
rich people,
but you need an asset,
your you,
your wire riding on the wave of
contemporary populism and populism.
As Steve Bannon says,
could go either way.
It could go either way.
Eva,
ordinary people go,
yeah,
it's really going to help me to
deregulate the already powerful people
that are trotting around the globe like
ogres or we could through this wave of
populism,
empower community,
empower ordinary people,
and we are all ordinary people
ultimately in spite of our various
individual skills and they don't like
the word capitalism.
I don't like the the goals.
Your individual should be the goal.
I just send a message and be rewarded
this much and you decided that the
balance in your life is that you want to
instead go and gifts the community more
that should be allowed,
but why should you be able to govern how
much I give to the community versus how
much I get to myself.
That's wrong.
That makes you a dictator.
You decided that you know so well about
society that you're going to sell
everybody.
I didn't say that,
but I'm saying the big year,
like the concepts that you're preaching
here because you don't like to name what
you're saying,
right?
You don't like it when I say social.
No,
I didn't say that.
Yeah,
you drew you.
You're basically telling us and this
entire podcast and the next minute you
say,
I'm a consultant.
A bit of both.
Conservative,
Communist,
complicated.
These are times when the old divide,
excuse me,
and the old polarities are starting to
dissolve.
While we feel like people are becoming
more and more opposed to each other,
I think we're becoming closer and closer
to rejecting the systems that oppress
us,
not just economically that's a.
These are the crumbs I'm talking about
spiritually preventing people from
realizing their potential.
So I do believe in the power of
previously oppressed people,
but I think to like people,
you know,
as an individual,
I wouldn't like to continue to revel in
my misery or this and that.
We will want to do.
People do need to progress.
I'm like to deny like something as God
historically scarring I slavery,
so why would I be scarred by that were
over.
There is some evidence to suggest that
there is a hereditary
trauma.
I mean even psychological leftist
professor,
probably Cambridge because we'll the
same way that we evolve features.
We evolve emotionally and something is
as recent as that.
That is so ridiculous.
Everybody that has been.
Everybody feels like it's.
Everyone has been a slave at some point.
There was slavery here too.
Did you feel your slavery pain the other
week?
I'm from Essex.
Should we hold hands?
No.
Slavery that we both experienced.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
that feels so good to acknowledge.
Finally something that we both feel
might be concerned.
Candice.
Now listen,
Jenny,
my.
You've got his picture before pose her
elegant.
It's so sad.
No,
this.
This feels good,
but why?
Why would you think that people should
revel in mystery,
but we have to acknowledge pain.
You have to acknowledge that history has
happened.
What do you think about reparations?
The pain doesn't exist anymore.
What do we think about against it?
There would be no United Kingdom.
There will be no United States slippery
slope I've ever heard in my entire life.
Why?
What'd you think it would slip and slide
off quality?
No,
it wouldn't.
It wouldn't.
It would go into.
Okay,
but before,
before we were slaves in Africa,
we have.
Everybody has.
How has it in their past.
So how far back do you want to do
operations?
Roman empire.
Do you want to go back to that?
Do the Italian.
So everybody.
Reparations.
You get what I'm saying?
It's the slope is so slippery that you
can't make a point in society.
And by the way,
the best reparations,
the most successful people in the world
ring lines a system is a line you're
currently saying,
well,
let's not do any reparation.
No,
I don't believe there's no share any
wealth.
That's where the lines are currently
drawn.
So for me,
people that talk about reparations,
they've raised an important point by
exposing the fact that they use,
excuse me,
great countries about the United
Kingdom,
United States of America,
entirely founded on stolen his books.
You talk about taxation of the rich have
been stealing them.
What the fuck was slavery?
What the fuck was colonialism other than
stealing on a massive scale?
You can't have one without the other.
What I'm saying is that slavery still
exists in Africa today.
So for people to pretend that we were,
it was stolen from him like we were
kings and Queens and Africa's a myth.
No,
we were slaves were sold by our own
people.
So who are we met at the Africans we met
at the Americans.
It's a piece of furniture that happened.
It was very unfortunate.
Okay.
But it happened to be.
It is unfortunate,
but it happens everywhere there.
There's not that long ago.
No,
but since the beginning of time there
had been slaves.
So how do you decide that one black
slaves in America are the ones deserve
reparations?
Every.
The slope is.
And let me tell you something.
You.
No,
no,
no.
The challenge.
Black Americans.
Would you rather be in America today?
Do you wish it never happened?
They single black America and I've met
will tell you if they wish they lived in
Africa to say,
do you want to know why?
Because all the opportunities are in
America.
Black Americans today.
If we banded together would be the 30,
30,
I think number six in terms of the
economy in the world.
How'd you mean band together?
Like if we said we're going to carol and
little country black Americans,
so yeah,
we would be.
Would be ranked as like that happened
it.
Hey,
the way the visa people are talking to
just my.
We have self segregation happening in
America now,
which is about the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life.
I want you to be more optimistic.
I wouldn't you be more ambitious.
I feel like you were there.
How old are you?
If I'm a 29.
Oh my God.
Is that older?
Young?
Yeah.
Holder young.
Young.
What happened?
We have a.
hold on.
Let me do this sort of questions that
are easy to make clips out of.
I might have to.
Jennifer.
Things we might have to lift up is.
I think I've called you love twice.
Like six to go see.
There we go.
Now we're living.
It didn't mean to do it.
I'm in love as in an affection towards
you.
So.
But that's what I'm.
That's what I'm saying.
It's like,
why can't you say that?
Because some people find it offensive.
I hate the society we live in.
It's a joke,
right?
This is know.
Um,
I mean the side of trying to create
leftists only you only elect this would
pull that out of a clip and say it's
wrong.
Only left.
This gets mad when a,
a man opens the door and the real power
though.
No,
yeah,
they do because they're dressing it up
as feminism when in reality they're
gaining power.
But power is control over resources.
They just saying something to your soul
rose thing.
Of course there is.
When they,
when they freak out,
they try to,
to stop.
Breck had enough from being nominated to
the supreme court.
That was radical feminism.
He never sexually harass anybody.
Never happened.
I'm sure different kind of interview,
but have a field day with you because
the things you say like,
uh,
like properly rape is a thing now.
So we have to acknowledge it right now.
Now listen to A.
I'm going to stop you.
You're scared.
I'm not scared that I will say for you,
which is a wonderful quality and a
human,
where do you think true power lies
within the individual,
within yourself?
Well,
that's not true.
Is it because of the individual on this
planet is as powerful as Halliburton?
Well,
what do you.
What's your measure of power or ability
to get what you want done,
but what?
What do you want done?
That varies from individual to
individual.
So the power rests with the individual.
There is a uniform concept of will and
the people whose will is most easily
exerted.
There is a,
there is a hierarchy,
so I would say and the most powerful
people that people are generally born
into positions where the power was
already had already been accumulating.
All.
Alright.
But it's definitely true though,
and we're going to edit this so that
your response will be rough.
You've really changed my mind.
What you said,
you really changed my mind.
What you said was so insightful and so.
Yes.
I'm so glad to be here.
That's the trailer candies.
Well,
about this thing here.
Um,
do you think this is a good question
jenny?
Jenny wrote this question,
do you think the old Protestant myth
that working hard and personal
responsibility is deployed to prevent
governments
and authorities from actually helping?
Yeah,
it is,
isn't it?
Well,
yeah.
the idea is that we don't want
governments.
We,
we,
we believe in ourselves on a community
level so that,
that's the,
that's the goal is to realize that the
job of a government wasn't supposed to
be to,
to um,
government.
Every piece of our lives,
you know,
the government in many ways is trying to
replace God,
you know,
at people you through like that idea,
and I agree with it.
But statism and post Westphalian tree
nationalism simply replace the notion of
a,
an omnipotent and that,
that that's definitely true.
Well,
according to my little brain right now,
what about this thing here?
I want to ask our county West Corp,
that's a very sort of important
celebrity type of thing.
So,
uh,
what happened there?
Uh,
which,
which ports,
like he's banging into,
you know,
he says,
I've been used to mean by first and
foremost.
I don't,
I,
I know Kanye didn't write those sweet.
It's not how he speaks,
but Kanye realized very soon,
and this is the cleanest I can say it
because I did make a promise to him that
I wouldn't speak about this publicly,
but Kanye realized,
I think very quickly that there no such
thing as doing politics halfway.
You are either fully in and you risk
everything around you,
your friends,
your family,
your,
wherever you are in life,
your business negotiations,
like in the way that trump did or you're
out of it.
And unfortunately in this I guess is
public.
Uh,
you know,
Kim always says that she disagrees with
Kanye.
I'm politically and so for him to cause
a tremor in his life all around him,
he has children,
young,
you know,
young children.
Um,
that's a risky deal to make.
I mean,
he also has his big adidas deal.
That's a risky thing to do,
to go into politics and upon and Maggie
had to talk to trump and the left
controls hollywood.
I mean,
that's just what it is,
you know,
that,
um,
they all think the same.
Every award show.
It's not even funny anymore.
It's just like,
just talk about trump for the next two
hours.
I mean,
it's a joke.
They've ruined comedy.
Um,
and I think that a cognac,
it was receiving a lot of heat and he
respectfully needed to step out of the
kitchen.
I,
you know,
I guess I was his entrance into positive
politics and I was just entrance out.
It was him tweeting me that caused the
entire firestorm and it was him tweeting
me that was the same way out.
But I deeply respect him.
You mean the.
So you feel like when people get
involved in politics is,
it's all consuming.
Oh,
it's it.
Every layer of your life they,
they try to find everything you've ever
done in your entire life.
They try to get people to speak out
against you.
The amount of fights I've had with my
family because reporters call and say
things that I never said,
Hey,
Kenneth tells me you're this or that.
And then your parents obviously think
that they're telling the truth and they
get all flustered and they are super
proud of you.
I,
Hey,
grandpa loves Robert and Granddad
applebee's.
I,
yeah,
well I'm his child,
I'm just,
he,
he's somebody that started his life on a
sharecropping farm and worked his butt
off.
Never said he couldn't do something
because he was black or he was just
advantage because he grew up in a
segregated south.
He just worked hard,
kept his head down,
do what he had to do and found success.
And I know I definitely got my
motivation in life from his sort of
steady counseling.
He's like a no nonsense.
Um,
he sounds like an incredible man.
Yeah.
How do,
what do you feel like success is gonna
look like for you ultimately?
You know,
what would it feel like success for you?
How?
What would make you fulfilled?
Candice?
I think first and foremost,
cracking the black vote.
Showing that we're not a monolith,
that we think differently and that we're
starting to listen to the policies.
Not The emotional argument for any group
of individuals to be voting in 90
percent margins for one party shows you
that at,
especially when that party has never
done anything that has served you,
shows you that we've made an emotional
investment into politics and ultimately
harmed our personal lives.
Do not think is significantly.
There are only two parties in.
Neither of those parties meaningfully
represent the interests of people who
have been oppressed.
I think trump represents a whole new
house,
but because he's independent,
they all hate them.
Everybody hated trump.
Doesn't know my average except for the
American people.
If you could ask these people,
I in trump,
like trump being hated an independent.
It doesn't help ordinary people because
he's.
He's,
he's,
he's bringing jobs back to America.
We were selling our soul overseas and we
were there teaching us to hate being
American.
That teaching on industrializing are
actually factories and manufacturing.
Jobs are coming back and people don't
really true though,
because you know how they let you work
in politics more than I do.
You know,
it's like a game.
there's not a lot of truth in that world
alive aside.
Well,
I,
it's not that different.
That's why I travel six days a week and
I traveled to every state,
even to Hawaii.
The love and comfort in your life.
Who looks after you?
I can't,
I can't.
She snapped her.
You know,
her name is bear.
Hey,
bear really have so much in common.
Well,
yes,
but also my bear will beat your barrier.
Disagree?
I don't think so because he's like a mad
woman for cat or fast.
She left.
Ally takes out a wall at the top of the
top of the food chain because you know
what the problem is?
Is that a,
um,
that dog is a painting.
Well,
I'm not gonna get into the dock.
We've got sandwiched.
Painted nails.
Important though.
We should maybe another time.
One of these days when people.
Are you pretty strong when them people
are protesting,
you know,
your career,
your,
uh,
like I've watched some videos where
there's people protesting the back and
stuff.
You hold yourself together world.
Oh yeah.
They're totally like insane.
But then you feel like,
why don't,
why don't you feel like this is what I
feel like I watched,
like right when people,
because I'm fascinated and I kind of
admire the bravery I got to say that.
Um,
but do not feel like that you want to
receive and give love to people.
Does that not,
is that not sort of high on your agenda?
No,
of course it is.
And I do.
I received so much love because once
people have this political awakening,
um,
and they realized that everything has
been sold to them as lie.
Nothing feels better than self
empowerment.
Actually feeling like you can do it when
it comes within you,
you know,
he is a strong emotion but doesn't feel
as good as love.
You know,
saying my life sucks because of all of
you.
It doesn't feel as good as saying I can
do anything.
Of course when you mean personal value,
but like,
but like that is not the clearest and
most obvious manifestation manifestation
of love from my family.
Do you?
That's good.
Because the most obvious manifestation
of love that I can think of is to accept
and understand other people that people
have had different experiences to you in
life and that of course,
and I accept that we're always going to
have different experiences.
That's called life.
You can't create a system where
everybody is equal.
It doesn't exist in module ring,
right?
It just doesn't exist.
That's utopia there though before we got
the fire station.
But yeah,
I mean I,
I look for love in my personal life.
I don't look for love in my,
in my political life.
I understand that when you know your why
should,
why should the political will be
exempted.
We're human beings because what I,
what I am doing is giving them the power
to go into their personal lives and,
and,
and feel cold beer candies is what
you're actually doing is wrangling them
into this,
into sort of a corralling them into a
position where the most powerful people
in the world can continue to benefit
from them.
Because whilst I agree that there are
bogus sort of lefty,
Democrat people that contribute a lot to
the debate and I don't support the sort
of the,
the mainstream media and the narratives
that they put forward in like the cuffs
in new arguing very articulately and
brilliantly with people,
I feel that the most people,
powerful people in the world will
benefit if other.
If people believe in individual power,
people do need to collect the virus to
challenge power is the only way we can
ever change the collectivization.
That's the APP.
I believe that that's a terrible,
terrible thing for community is what we
fall.
Even communities,
of course by collectivism,
collectivism leads to communism.
So I think it's important to acknowledge
the individuals to be the same as the
big argument is we don't have to be
defined by our history that we can
create new futures,
so collective and community based
ideologies need and automatically lead
to state communism in the Gulag.
For me though,
I only spent 10 minutes and I thought it
was going quite well.
We had a lovely Democrat community.
You did okay,
but you,
you couldn't,
you know,
say what the role of government was
going to be and I'm telling you,
look it,
it's,
it's hard to say with the snowflakes,
okay,
you and I meditate.
We're not special.
Snowflakes were not original.
Every system has turned into nuts.
It's been.
It's been trying to be a blizzard.
Storm,
snow cats where you are.
There's no question.
That's what I am.
Very,
very wonderful bug.
Think you must be a bit more kind to
people.
Compassionate for people that feel like
in my face,
calling me a white supremacist.
It's not nice to Shriek at people.
I agree with you to find compassion in
my belly when I'm being shrieked and
called the white supremacists.
Somebody read a guardian or don't get
angry.
What did our Lord do?
He fat.
Forgive them.
They know not what they do.
Forgiveness,
endless forgiveness,
endless love.
I do love life.
You've been put in a position of power.
Then you have an obligation to be
loving.
That's your first obligation,
right?
Not to be a practical because I don't
think you've been given her enough love
in this grand.
Sounds absolutely amazing that when
you're a little kid,
I don't mean now all that crap in the
media and I love it.
Sounds amazing.
Yeah.
But with this guy,
I know my grandma who passed Nola,
Nolan rock sound terrific.
People such,
you know,
like they say that they're there.
Um,
well because I was trying to assert
control in my life and,
and that was the way that I dealt with
it.
But I mean I have.
What about other people who have gotten
a wreck?
Shit.
What'd you start to them back up?
You wouldn't say that.
No,
I understand it.
Obviously on a more.
In the same way that you would
understand drug addiction on a more
molecular level because you've lived it.
I would tell them that they need to
identify what they're trying to control.
When I'm talking to drug addicts,
I say this,
some were wearing new.
You do not think that you are beautiful.
You have been hurt.
There is a way out of this pain for
spiritual connection to one another
through service,
through higher ideals,
to recognize your own beauty and to
realize it.
That's the sort of thing,
and I have to say to them,
right,
it's not God different though.
I'm sure it is.
I don't.
I can't give that pep speech.
They look at you and they'd be like,
yeah,
no,
they'd be the anorexics.
I've never known such complexity.
Yeah,
it's very complex.
It really is,
but I have to believe that love is more
important than hate.
That unity and togetherness.
More powerful than individually,
but it.
But once you.
Once you.
You have to empower anybody videos.
I do not want to be the same person that
you are.
I don't want to be treated like where
the same person.
I don't want to be the same person that
a person around me is.
I don't want to be treated as if we're
the exact same person and you can cookie
cut society and say,
Oh,
this is what Qantas likes for breakfast,
so that must be.
We're all just going to have the same
cereal for breakfast.
I don't like that we are individuals.
You should celebrate the individual.
The individual should come together and
form a community that takes care of
issues for individuals.
I can't take care of themselves.
That's a good idea.
Now this,
um,
would you be willing if over time when
human beings come up with better ideas,
as human beings evolve,
if better ideas than free market
capitalism were to emerge,
would you be open to those ideas?
I love ideas.
If there was something better,
a better idea then globalized free
market capitalism exists in the realm of
infinite possibility through which all
realized it must have surely have
traveled.
There exists now,
better ideas,
ideas that are more fair,
more just they are there waiting to
happen,
these ideas and when they arrive,
which they will,
you will be open to them.
I will be the first person that opens my
loving arms and says,
come here and new idea that's going to
fix everything.
And then we probably just need 10,
15 minutes with my pant and be willing
to in that direction.
Alright,
well I think we've done as much as we
can given the limitations that we're
obviously working with them.
What do you think,
candice?
It's been lovely.
Been good at it because we're
essentially disagree on almost
everything.
Then agree quite strongly on some
things.
Right.
Well what is.
I've just taken a step further like you
actually agree with me.
I'd absolutely.
Everything that I'm saying you just
have.
You just had it plugged it in.
You just haven't plugged it in to
realize that it's actually a capitalist,
not crony capitalism,
but a capitalist society with free
markets that helps with people out of
poverty.
It's one steps off and these massive
regulation.
We've seen the results of that walk in,
walk in,
and then I took one step and you're here
and I'm like,
come back to us.
So hopefully I helped you a little bit.
See what can you wish your absolutely
charming.
That was amazing.
Thank you.
Fucking
awesome.